IT MARIO CORDERO MISTER OKAY
I'LL LET US PROCEED. A GOOD
MORNING- CALLING- THIS HEARING
OF THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
PORTS AND GOODS MOVEMENT TO
ORDER. I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO THE
HEARING. I BELIEVE SENATOR
GONZALEZ IS ON HERE AS WELL I
THINK BY PHONE OR BY VIDEO-
SIMILAR FONG I BELIEVE IS ON
HIS WAY AS SOON OVER VIA COULD
DO A IS HERE. AND I HOPE I SAID
YOUR NAME CORRECTLY GREAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND HE REPRESENTS
STOCKTON SO I AM VERY HAPPY TO
HAVE YOU HERE BECAUSE WE NEED
TO GET MORE MEMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE ENGAGE IN THE COURTS. AS
ALWAYS SAY THEIR SUPPORT EVERY
DISTRICT AND- YOU HAVE A
PARTNER DISTRICT A LOT OF
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE POURED THEIR
DISTRICT BUT- THEY ACTUALLY
HAVE A LOT OF GOOD COMING
THROUGH PORTS IN AND OUT OF
THEIR DISTRICT ALSO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUILAR CURRY.
WHO HAS A LOT OF AGRICULTURE
AND JUST GENERAL INTEREST IN
MAKING SURE THE GOODS MOVE AND
OUT BE AT WINE BE IT LOTS OF
OTHER THINGS WALNUT SUCCESS
RUPTURE. EVERYTHING YEAH SOCIAL.
THEY ARE HERE. BEFORE WE BEGIN
I HAVE A STATEMENT READ
REGARDING OUR PROCESS TODAY WE
CONTINUE TO PRACTICE FISCAL
DISTANCING HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM SO WE ARE ONLY ABLE ABLE
TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE TO WATCH AND PARTICIPATE
IN THE HEARING. WE'RE ALSO
REQUIRING THAT MASS BE WARNED
AND PHYSICAL DISTANCING BE
MAINTAINED BY ALL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. TESTIFYING WEATHER
HERE IN THE ROOM OR AT A VIDEO
CONFERENCING STATE. IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A MASK WE CAN PROVIDE
ONE FOR YOU WE HAVE SEVERAL.
OPTIONS FOR TESTIMONY TODAY. IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
COMMENTS YOU MAY APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE WE CALL FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THE END OF THE
HEARING. PUBLIC COMMENT WOULD
BE AT THE END OF THE HEARING
MEMBERS THE PUBLIC MAY ALSO.
PROVIDE COMMON AND ONE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS. OR USING ARE MODERATED
TELEPHONE SERVICE. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS THE
CALL IN NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR
THREE SEVEN. YOU'RE NOT CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON YOUR
SCREEN THAT NUMBER IS ALSO ON
THE SCREEN IF YOU'RE CALLING
IN. PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE IT'S IMPORTANT
ALL BACKGROUND NOISE THIS
INCLUDES MUTING YOUR LIVESTREAM
BROADCAST. AND YOUR SMART
DEVICES. PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE
LIMITED TO ONE MINUTE PER
PERSON IF YOU'RE HAVING ANY
PROBLEMS. WITH THE MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL MY
OFFICE AT NINE ONE SIX. THREE
ONE NINE TWO ZERO SEVEN ZERO.
WE'RE ALSO ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY VIA EMAIL TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OT O'DONNELL. AT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOP. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE AS WE
IMPLEMENT THESE PRACTICES CAN
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU- SOME
OF OUR FONG HAS SHOWN UP THANK
YOU- HAS A LOT OF INTEREST
REPORTS THE A LOT OF GOODS IN
HIS DISTRICT MOVING AND OF
COURSE- BUT DOWN IN THE
BAKERSFIELD AREA. I REPRESENT
THE PORTS OF LONG BEACH AND-
LOS ANGELES THE TWO LARGEST
PORTS IN THE NATION. JUST AS
THESE PORTS ARE THE BACKBONE OF
OUR LOCAL ECONOMY IN THE LOS
ANGELES REGION. ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S PORTS PLAY A VITAL
ROLE IN OUR STATE'S ECONOMIC
SUCCESS. AND OUR RECOVERY FROM
THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
CALIFORNIA PORTS HANDLE 40% OF
CONTAINERIZED IMPORTS AND 30%
OF ALL EXPORTS. ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. WITH SUCH A MASSIVE
VOLUME OF CARGO COMING THROUGH
OUR PORTS THEY SERVE AS A MAJOR
DRIVER OF GOOD PAYING JOBS FOR
OUR STATE. MORE THAN ONE
MILLION JOBS IN CALIFORNIA AND
THREE MILLION JOBS NATIONWIDE
ARE LINKED TO TRADE COMING
THROUGH. OUR PORTS. I LIKE TO
SAY THAT THERE IS A PORT IN
EVERY DISTRICT IS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATORS REALIZE HOW MUCH OF
WHAT GOES ON AT OUR PORTS
DIRECTLY. IMPACTS THEIR
COMMUNITIES ARE ELEVEN PORTS IN
THE STATE THE TWO BIGGEST ARE
MY DISTRICT BUT BY NO MEANS
DOES THAT NOT MEAN THE OTHERS
ARE BORN THEY ALL SERVE A VITAL
FUNCTION. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY AND BEYOND. OVER THE
PAST YEAR. IS BECOME APPARENT
MORE MORE THAN EVER AS
CALIFORNIA PORTUGAL'S MOON
WORKERS HAVE SHOWN GREAT
RESILIENCE IN THE FACE OF
ADVERSITY AND UNCERTAINTY
CAUSED BY A WORLDWIDE PANDEMIC.
OUR MEN AND WOMEN ON THE FRONT
LINES AT A GREAT JOB SHOWING UP
TO WORK. THE CODE IS BEEN VERY
PRESENT ON THE DOCKS. AND-
THEY'VE REALLY- YOU KNOW. WHAT
CHART FOR CHARGING UNKNOWN
THERE'S BEEN SOME GREAT LOSS
THERE TOO THEY STEPPED UP TO
PROTECT THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
SUPPLY CHAIN SERVICE TESTING
HOMES FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
ASSIST IN THE DISTRIBUTION OF
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT. I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY DEEPEST
GRATITUDE TO OUR PORTS AND
GOODS MOVEMENT INDUSTRY WORKERS
EVERYONE FROM DOCKWORKERS TO
TRUCK DRIVERS TO WAREHOUSE
WORKERS AND EVEN THE FOLKS AT
THE PORT OF COURSE WHO HAVE
CONTINUED WORKING THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC TO KEEP CRUCIAL
GOODS LIKE FOOD AND MEDICAL
SUPPLIES ON OUR SHELVES THAT
CANNOT BE UNDERSCORED THAT HAS
NOT BEEN. DISCUSSED ENOUGH.
THIS HEARING WILL PROVIDE
MEMBERS OF THE INDUSTRY AN
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE
HOW THE PANDEMIC HAS IMPACTED
THEIR DAY TO DAY OPERATIONS.
AND HOW THEY HAVE RESPONDED.
BEYOND THEIR ECONOMIC IMPACT
CALIFORNIA PORTS ARE ALSO
LEADING THE WORLD IN
ENVIRONMENTAL INNOVATION. IF
THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT GOING
GREEN OR SOMETHING OF ARMALITE
SURE YOU. IT'S HAPPENING AT
LEAST AT THE PORTS OF LONG
BEACH. AND LA OVER THE PAST
DECADE THE PORTS AND GOODS
MOVEMENT INDUSTRY IS HELP TO
ACHIEVE MAJOR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
BUT OUR WORK ISN'T DONE YET WE
STILL NEED TO FIND A PATH TO
MEET CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS.
EMISSIONS REDUCTION GOALS. THAT
IS WHY. IT IS CRUCIAL THAT
STATE LATER STATE LEADERS WORK
TOGETHER WITH THE INDUSTRY TO
CRAFT WORKABLE REGULATIONS. AND
DELIVER RESOURCES THAT CAN HELP
THEM MAKE THEM TRANSITION TO AN
EVEN GREENER OPERATE TO EVEN
GREENER OPERATIONS. OVER THE
NEXT DECADE I WOULD SAY THE
FORCED ME TO MAKE GREEN TO GO
GREEN. TODAY WE ARE JOINED BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ CHAIR OF THE
SENATE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
PORTS AND GOODS MOVEMENT.
SENATOR ARE YOU THERE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SAY A FEW WORDS.
I
THINK WE'RE GONNA. MOVE ON
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK SHE'S
THERE YET SHE MAY STILL BE ON
THE FLOOR ON THE SENATE SIDE-
SO WILL. THAT CENTER GONZALEZ-
SAY HELLO WHEN SHE- GETS ON
THERE. AND SHE AGAIN IS A
STRONG ADVOCATE FOR PORTS. AND
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
REPORTS. AND GOODS MOVEMENT TO
OUR STATE AND CERTAINLY THE
REGION SHE REPRESENTS. I THINK
SENATOR GONZALEZ MIGHT BE THERE
I THINK I. EXCIDIO I AM HERE
CAN YOU HEAR ME OK I CAN HEAR
YOU OKAY MY FAULT I APOLOGIZE.
NO NO WORRIES I JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE YOU CAN OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL- AND ALL START OVER
AGAIN NO PROBLEM GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY GLAD TO BE HERE AS
CHAIR OF THE AD SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
ALSO CHAIR OF THE- WILL BE PRE
AUTHORIZED THE SENATE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON PORTS AND GOODS
MOVEMENT AND WE'RE JUST GLAD TO
JOIN YOU. TO DISCUSS THE IMPACT
ON COBIT NINETEEN ON A REPORT
STATEWIDE SUSTAINABILITY GOALS
FOR FREIGHT SECTOR AND THE
HIGHLIGHTS THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF OUR PORTS AND THE
WORK FORCE FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
MY DISTRICT IS HOME TO THE PORT
OF LONG BEACH THAT I SHARE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF DONALD I
THINK OUR PORT OF LONG BEACH
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR MARIO FOR
THAT. IN PORT OF LA- DIRECTOR
JEAN SOROKA FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK THERE AT THE PORTS AS WELL
AS MANY OF OUR I'LL W. YOU
WORKERS AND LOCALS THIRTEEN
SIXTY THREE NINETY. FOUR AND
MANY OF OUR TRUCK DRIVERS AND
WAREHOUSE WORKERS AS WELL WE
KNOW THAT OUR PORT FOR AN
ECONOMIC POWERHOUSE THAT
GENERATES APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
THOUSAND JOBS ABOUT ONE IN FIVE
IN LONG BEACH. CALIFORNIA PORTS
ALL OVER. HAVE AS A PIVOTAL
ROLE IN PROVIDING ESSENTIAL
GOODS FOR THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. DURING THIS PANDEMIC
OUR DOCK WORKERS AND TRUCK
DRIVERS AND WAREHOUSE. WORK
FORCE HAS CONTINUED TO SHOW UP.
AND IN MANY IN FACT MANY OF
THEM HAVE BEEN WORKING EXTENDED
HOURS. AS THEY PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES AS GUARDIANS
OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN DURING A
VERY CHALLENGING PANDEMIC. OUR
PORTS AND GOOD MOVEMENT
WORKFORCE DESERVE OUR RESPECT
OUR THANKS AND THEY DESERVE TO
BE RECOGNIZED AS THE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS THAT THEY ARE FOR
BEING. BY BEING QUITE OR TIES
FOR COPING NINETEEN RESOURCES
AND VACCINES AND I WAS GLAD TO
WORK WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL ON THIS VERY ISSUE.
I'M ALSO EXCITED TO HIGHLIGHT
TODAY SOME OF THE GREAT WORK
THAT IS HAPPENING AT OUR
CALIFORNIA PORTS TO MEET
STATEWIDE EMISSIONS. REDUCTION
TARGETS I KNOW THIS WILL NOT BE
EASY BUT WE WANT TO LEARN HOW
THE STATE CAN HELP IN A WAY IN.
AND AS CHAIR OF THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE I AM
EXCITED TO ENGAGE ALL OF YOU.
TO UNDERSTAND THE HURDLES AND
OPPORTUNITIES UP AHEAD. SO WE
CAN WORK TO THAT TOGETHER FOR A
BRIGHTER FUTURE FOR ALL OF OUR
CALIFORNIA PORTS. AGAIN THANK
YOU SO MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL AND THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR HAVING ME TODAY
AND- I LOOK FOR TO THE
DISCUSSION. GREAT THANK YOU DID
ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HERE JUST PUSH TO SAY SOMETHING
QUICKLY THEY WANT ANYTHING. NOW
LET'S MOVE ON AND- BURKE- WE
WILL MOVE ON TO- OUR OVERVIEW
OF CALIFORNIA PORTS- AND
FORTUNEGIANTS SOROKA. PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PORT AUTHORITIES AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE PORT
OF LA IS UNABLE TO JOIN US
TODAY. SO MARTHA MILLER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PORT
AUTHORITIES. WILL PROVIDE A
SHORT OVERVIEW OF CALIFORNIA'S
PORTS THE CHALLENGES THEY FACE
IN THE PAST YEAR. AND NOW THEY
HAVE DEMONSTRATED RESILIENCE IN
THE FACE OF THE CODE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC I'M MARTHA MILLER
UNIVERSITY. GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME AT THE
LAST MINUTE GOOD MORNING
CARADON OFTEN OCCUR GONZALEZ
THE MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. ON THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU THIS MORNING- AS- A
THOROUGH DONALD ADDED I'M
MARTHA MILLER SERVICE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PORT
AUTHORITIES. I'M AT TESTIFIED
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE ELEVEN
PUBLIC PARTS THAT CALL
CALIFORNIA HOME. I DO HAVE A
QUICK VIDEO KEVIN- I'M HOPING
THAT I CAN SHARE. CAN I CAN I
PLANT KEVIN AT THE GIVEDIRECTLY
HOSTS MAYBE. OKAY MAYBE NOT.
OKAY SO WE'LL MOVE ON FROM NOT-
HELP. THERE YOU GO HOLD ON.
SORRY EVERYONE.
HELLO. I DON'T.
APPLE. THE MORNING. APPLE. SO
I'M THERE MAY NOT HAVE BEEN
FOUND ON THAT WE'LL JUST MOVE
ON FROM THAT- WITHOUT THAT
WOULD BE A NICE WAY TO START IT
BUT IT MIGHT NOW PARKED OUT. OF
THE FIFTH THE WORLD'S FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY CALIFORNIA'S
CONTINUED GROWTH AND PROSPERITY
IS TIED TO INTERNATIONAL TRADE
AND ITS PARTS ARE THE LINCHPIN
OF ITS FREE INTERNATIONAL TRADE
SYSTEM PORTS ARE CALIFORNIA'S
DE FACTO TRADE STRATEGY CAPITAL
PORT SERVE AS BOTH THE STATE
AND NATION'S GATEWAY TO THE
GLOBAL ECONOMY COMBINED WE
COMPRISE THE MOST PRODUCTIVE
SYSTEMS OF COURTS IN THE NATION
MORE THAN 40% OF THE TOTAL
CONTAINERIZED CARGO ENTRY IN
THE UNITED STATES AND ALMOST
30% OF THE NATION'S EXPORTS
FLOW THROUGH THE PORTS IN THE
GOLDEN STATE. THE CARGO FLOWING
THROUGH CALIFORNIA PARTS
ACCOUNTS FOR OVER NINE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS AND ECONOMIC
IMPACTS NATIONALLY AND OVER
FIVE MILLION JOBS NATIONALLY AS
THE COVERED NINETEEN PANDEMIC
BEGAN THERE WAS WIDESPREAD
SPECULATION THAT A PORT
SHUTDOWN WAS IMMINENT RESULTING
AND CUT THE CONSUMER PANIC
BUYING OF EVERYDAY GETS
CALIFORNIANS PARTS REMAINS
CLEAR WE NEED TO KEEP CARGO
LIVING FOR ITS PART THE PART OF
LOS ANGELES WORK TO ENSURE PORT
OPERATIONS CONTINUED UNABATED
THIS INCLUDED WORKING WITH
STATE AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO
ENSURE THAT EMERGENCY ORDERS
RECOGNIZE WORKERS. ACROSS THE
SUPPLY CHAIN AS THE FEDERAL.
THE SAN PEDRO PARK COME. BEGAN
TO ENTER MEASURES TO PREVENT
AND REDUCE THE RISK OF SPREAD
OF THE PIVOT NINETEEN VIRUS.
THE INTERNATIONAL LONGSHORE AND
WAREHOUSE UNION MODIFIED THERE
DISPATCHING PRACTICES AND WORK
WITH THEIR EMPLOYEES
REPRESENTED BY THE PACIFIC
MARITIME ASSOCIATION. TO
DEVELOP PROTOCOLS TO CLEAN
EQUIPMENT BETWEEN CHEFS.
DESPITE THE NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS SEVERAL PARTS FACED A
SHORTAGE OF CLEANING SUPPLIES
AND PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. INDIVIDUAL PARTS
STEPPED UP. AT THE PORT OF
OAKLAND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
DANNY WANTED HIS TEAM HELP
THOUSANDS OF PASSENGERS
DISEMBARK THE GRANDPARENTS FAST
AND MAKE THEIR WAY TO
QUARANTINE SOUNDS. THE PORT OF
LONG BEACH THE PORT WHY NINI
AND OTHER KAPPA MEMBERS- OPEN
TESTING SITES FOR WATER FOR
WORKERS. THE PART OF LOS
ANGELES SERVED AS THE HOME FOR
THAT U. S. SENATE AFTER PERCY
WHICH WAS DISPATCHED A SANDAL
IS DURING THE FIRST EXPECTED.
SURGE OF QUEBEC NINETEEN
PATIENTS. DESPITE THE HEROIC
EFFORTS OF KAPPA MEMBERS PARTS
HAVE NOT BEEN IMMUNE TO THE
WORST IMPACTS OF THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC YOU'LL HEAR FROM MANY
OF THEM TODAY ON THE SPECIFIC
IMPACT THAT THEY'RE FACING. LOS
ANGELES LONG BEACH IN OAKLAND
THE THREE LARGEST CONTAINER
PORTS IN THE STATE EXPERIENCED
HUGE SHOCK TO THE GLOBAL TRADE.
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
BECAUSE ONE OF THE MOST EROTIC
AND VOLATILE YEARS IN TERMS OF
CONTAINER VOLUMES. IN EARLY
TWENTY TWENTY CHINA'S BATTLE
AGAINST THE PANDEMIC CAUSED A
HALL IN FACTORY PRODUCTION
FOLLOWED BY CANCELED SAILINGS
AND THEN A DROP IN U. S.
CONSUMER ACTIVITY AS AMERICA
SHUT DOWN ITS ECONOMY. AS A
RESULT VOLUMES PLUMMET BY 90%
IN THE FIRST HALF OF TWENTY
TWENTY. IN THE SECOND HALF OF
THE YEAR AS CHINESE
MANUFACTURING RESUMES AND U. S.
RETAILERS STARTED TO REPLENISH
THEIR DEPLETED INVENTORIES
CONSUMER DEMAND REBOUNDED
CAUSING AN UNPRECEDENTED IMPORT
SEARCH. WHICH NEARLY MADE OUT
FOR THE EARLIER VOLUME
DECLINED. THE COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS ALSO CAUSED AND
OBSERVE SHIFTED BUYING PATTERNS
FROM SERVICES TO GET WHICH
MANIFESTED IN AN IMPORT SURGE
THAT HAS STRAINED THE OVERALL
SUPPLY CHAIN. APPROXIMATELY ONE
THIRD OF ALL CONTAINERIZED
CARGO IS TRUCKED TO REGIONAL
WAREHOUSES DESPITE THE FACT
THAT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS
HOME TO ONE OF THE LARGEST
CONCENTRATION OF WAREHOUSES IN
THE WORLD. APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT EIGHT BILLION SQUARE FEET
IN THE REGION IN. THE
WAREHOUSES ARE FULL SIMPLY. PUT
THERE IS NO WHERE TO PUT THE
CARGO. AS A RESULT. ARE LEFT AT
THE MARINE TERMINAL LEADING TO
A STEADY BACKUP OF SHIPS AT THE
SAN PEDRO BAY PARK COMPLEX. AT
THIS COMPLEX VESSELS AT ANCHOR
WAITING UP TO TWO WEEKS BEFORE
RECEIVING AN OPETH ASSIGNMENT
TO BE UNLOADED. AS A RESULT TO
EASE CONGESTION BLANK SAILINGS
ARE ANTICIPATED FOR MARCH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WELL
HISTORICALLY THERE IS A DECLINE
IN CHINESE FACTORY PRODUCTION
DUE TO LUNAR NEW YEAR WE DO NOT
ANTICIPATE THIS WILL CREATE ANY
RISK BY. REGULAR VESSEL TRAFFIC
SHOULD BE RETURNED BY JUNE OR
JULY OF THIS YEAR. ANOTHER
IMPACT OF IMPACT OF MAXED OUT
WAREHOUSE CAPACITY AT THAT
CARGO OWNERS HAVE RESORTED TO
USING CONTAINERS AS WAREHOUSES.
IN NORMAL TIMES WHEN IMPORT
CONTAINERS PICKED UP AT THE
PORT IT TAKES THREE DAYS FOR
THAT CONTAINER TO BE DEMANDS.
AND RETURN TO THE POOR AT THE
EMPTY CONTAINER. PRESENTLY THE
CYCLE IS TAKING TEN DAYS AS A
RESULT THE SYSTEM AS A WHOLE IS
EXPERIENCING A SHORTAGE OF
CONTAINERS. THE SHORTAGE OF
CONTAINERS HAS NOT GONNA FAX
FIRST CARRIERS HAVE MADE A
BUSINESS DECISION TO CYCLE THE
EMPTIES BACK TO ASIA IN ORDER
TO PICK UP THE NEXT ROUND OF
IMPORTS RATHER THAN ALLOW THAT
CONTAINER TO BE LOADED WITH
EXPORTS. THIS BUSINESS DECISION
IS DRIVEN BY THE CURRENT PRICE
DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN IMPORT
LOADS VERSUS EXPERT LET'S THIS
DECISION HAS IMPACTED EXPORTERS
ACROSS THE US. THE SURGEON
CARGO HAPPENED AT A TIME WHEN
OUR WORKFORCE HAS BEEN SEEING A
SURGE IN COVERT CASES. FROM
MARCH TO DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
THERE WERE FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY NINE REPORTED CASES OF
KOBE ACROSS THE CALIFORNIA LONG
SHORT WORKERS. IN THE FIRST SIX
WEEKS OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE
HAVE FOUR HUNDRED FIFTEEN NEW
CASE THAT'S- CURRENTLY ABOUT
EIGHT HUNDRED LONG SURE WORKERS
ARE NOT WORKING BECAUSE OF
COMBAT. CALIFORNIA PORTS ARE IN
NEED OF RELIEF WHETHER IN THE
FORM OF PRIORITIZE ACCESS TO
VACCINE OR IN THE FORM OF
RELIEF FINDING. PARTS HAVE BEEN
PASSED OVER IN EVERY CALVET
RELIEF PACKAGE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL. TOGETHER WE MUST
ADVOCATE FOR FULL FUNDING OF
THE MARITIME TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM OUR MERCHANTS THE RELIEF
PROGRAM. TO SUPPORT PARTS AND
THEIR TENANTS. I SECURING
RELIEF WE CAN ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S PARTS ARE THERE
FOR THE STATE AS PARTNERS IN
RECOVERY. AS OTHER STATES AND
COUNTRIES HAVE RECOGNIZED PARTS
ARE ECONOMIC ASSETS THAT CAN BE
HARNESSED TO DRIVE ECONOMIC
RESURGENCE. CALIFORNIA'S PORTS
SERVE AS GATEWAYS CONNECTING
EVERY CORNER OF THE COUNTRY TO
MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
COUNTRIES IN THE WORLD. AS
PARTS WE NEED A LINE POLICY
PLANNING AND PROGRAMS ACROSS
ALL OF THESE AREAS
TRANSPORTATION ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. WE SEE IT
HAPPENING IN OTHER STATES AND
WE NEED TO DEVELOP A SIMILAR
STRATEGY RIGHT HERE WE SEE THAT
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT'S FORM SHOULD BE
A TRUE TRADE COMPETITIVE
STRATEGY FOR CALIFORNIA. THE
HARNESSES THE UNIQUE ATTRIBUTES
AND COMMERCIAL CHARACTERISTICS
OF EVERYONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC PARTS. LASTLY WE CANNOT
FORGET THAT CALIFORNIA PORT
COMPETITIVENESS MUST COMPLEMENT
AND BALANCE OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP. ENSURING CARGO AND
PASSENGERS ARE NOT DIVERTED TO
DIRTY AIR MORE CARBON INTENSIVE
GATEWAYS AS SMART POLICY. NO
PORTS AROUND THE COUNTRY HAVE
MATCH THE INVESTMENTS THE
CALIFORNIA PARTS ON THEIR
TENANTS HAVE MADE IN REDUCING
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS AND
GREENHOUSE GASES. SETTING ASIDE
THE CLEANER ACTION PLANS THAT
MANY OF THE PARTS HAVE ADOPTED
INCLUDING SAN PEDRO BAY PORTS
WHICH HAVE RESULTED IN
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS AND
GREENHOUSE GASES. CALIFORNIA
PARTS ARE ENVIRONMENTALLY
DOLLARS MANY OF THEM WILL SHARE
THEIR INDIVIDUAL SUCCESS
STORIES OF THE BUYER MINISTER
CHIP WITH YOU TODAY AS PART OF
THE PANEL. WORKINGWITH YOU WE
SEEK TO BUILD TOWARDS OUR
CLIMATE CHANGE GOALS WHILE
CONTINUING TO PURSUE TRADE
COMPETITIVENESS AND WORKFORCE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR COMMUNITIES.
THIS RENEWED AND REDEFINED
PARTNERSHIP. IS THE SUMMONS UP
OF OUR MESSAGE TO OUR LEADERS
IN SACRAMENTO. TODAY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DEVELOPING THESE
IDEAS WITH YOU AND YOUR STAFF
THANK YOU. THANK YOUARE MARTHA
MILLER EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA PORTS
ASSOCIATION. AND I THINK ONE OF
THE HIGHLIGHTS YOU SPOKE ABOUT
MOST PEOPLE IN RECOGNIZE UNLESS
YOU'RE FROM THE AREA THERE ARE
MORE SHIPS. OUT ON THE- ON THE
ON THE ON AND OFF THE BEACH IN
LONG BEACH AND PROBABLY I'VE
EVER BEEN BEFORE- THE OTHER
AFFLUENT FIVE FORTY TO FORTY
FIVE SHIPS ANCHORED ALL THE WAY
DOWN TO HUNTINGTON BEACH.
BECAUSE THE BACKUP IS AS
SIGNIFICANT BACK UP- BECAUSE AS
SHE STATED THE WAREHOUSES ARE
FULL THE DOCKS ARE FULL SO
THESE FOLKS ARE WAITING- TO
UNLOAD. THEIR CARGO FOR VARIETY
REASONS AND THE CHINESE YOU
KNEW YOUR PLACE IN THEIR LITTLE
BIT COVERT PLACE AND THEY'RE A
LITTLE BIT- AND- KIND OF THE
BACKLOG I ASSUME PLACE BACK
PLACE AND A LITTLE BIT TOO. SO
LET'S MOVE ON OUR PANEL AND OF
THE PANELS COULD PLEASE STICK
TO THEIR- THEIR GIVEN- BUT WE
GAVE THEM- IN A SPECIFIC AMOUNT
OF TIME- BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT
STE A SIMILAR AGUILAR CREE HAS.
SOMETHING SHE WANTS TO SAY.
THANK YOU ARE. YOUR YOUR-
PRESENT- YOU JUST SAID. THAT I
THOUGHT WAS INTERESTING. THERE
WOULD NOT BE ANY RELIEF UNTIL
JUNE OR JULY- WHAT ARE THE
INDICATORS TO TELL. THAT WE
WOULD KNOW THAT WE WOULD. BE
ABLE TO GET OUR- OUR PRODUCT
OUT BY JUNE OR JULY IS THERE'S
A SOME INDICATORS THAT WE
SHOULD BE AWARE OF- I'M FROM
THE ARAB WORLD AND WE ARE JUST.
REALLY STRETCHING IT WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF US
IMPORTS COMING IN BUT WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO EXPORTER STUFF OUT SO
I'M JUST WONDERING IF YOU COULD
GIVE US SOME IDEA. SO WE WOULD
HAVE SOME CONFIDENCE THAT THAT
WOULD BE GENERAL JULY WHICH I'M
HOPING IT'S SOONER BUT. YEAH I
THINK YOU KNOW WE HOPE THAT WE
HAVE THAT CONFIDENCE I
WONDERING IF MARIO CORDERO IS
ON THE LINE I FEEL LIKE IT'S
SPEAK TO MORE OF THE SPECIFICS.
OKAY THAT'S FINE DECATUR'S. YES
WHEN WE DO THIS COULD WE WERE
MARIO COMES ON MARS GONNA
SPEAKING WE GET TALK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE LONG
BEACH LA SITUATION WITH THE-
THE BACKUP- AND I THINK I DON'T
THINK I DON'T THINK SHE SINGLE
TAKE TILL JUNE TO GET THE- THE
CAR THAT'S OUT THERE NOW AND I
THINK REALLY WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
IS. AS SHIPS COMING JUST GONNA
TAKE THAT. THAT AMOUNT OF TIME.
TO GET THE SHIPS THERE IN THEIR
THEIR STANDARD TURNAROUND TIME.
CONTINUE TO LISTEN BUT I'VE
WHEN SHE SAID JUNE OR JULY
TWENTY YEARS WENT UP YEAH THEY
SHOULD TOM THIS IS A THIS. IS A
SITUATION WE NEED TO DEAL WITH-
SO THAT. GO ON TO OUR FIRST
PANEL FREE FROM. DEVIN DIRECTOR
OF GOODS MOVE AND SUSTAINABLE.
FREIGHT UNIT GATHERED FROM THE
CALIFORNIA. GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT MR RIMMER'S. GOOD
MORNING- CHAIRMAN OF DONALD
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SHARE
THIS VERY. THE NEW SOME
ADMINISTRATION RECOGNIZES THAT
ARE HIGHLY FUNCTIONAL SUPPLY
CHAIN IS CRITICAL IN THE
FEDERAL ON ONE. OF THE PROVIDE
NEEDED MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND-
YOU CAN. ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
SPECIAL YOU TO EVERY WITH IN
THEIR HARD WORK WAS PASSED.
ASSEMBLY IT'S BY WHEN YOUR
COMMON AND MARK WAS PROMISED
CALIFORNIA HAS A VERY MARITIME
LAW FORCE. WHICH WE ARE MUCH
MANAGEMENT. IT IS CLEAR THAT
CAN AND DEMOCRATS IS THERE A
WAY TO TURN. HIS VOLUME ON. IS
THAT NOW NO. HERE YEAH IT'S
JUST A MORE IT'S- SORRY MAYBE
COULD A LITTLE CLOSE I'M SORRY.
THE BILL PER MINUTE. IS THAT
BETTER- KEEP GOING. OKAY WELL
FOR THE COMPANY YEAH I'VE NEVER
HEARD OF THE NEED TO MAINTAIN A
HUNDRED FUNCTIONS OF FORTUNE
THERE ARE SEVERAL PARTICIPANTS
MAKING. YOU WANT TO GET BACK
WITH. FOR HER WE MUST CONTINUE
TO OR NINETEEN ECONOMIC FOR.
BECAUSE REPUBLICAN CORPO SO WE
CONTINUE DEPART WORKING WITH
THE PUBLIC SO BOB CORKER.
ASSEMBLY SUPPORTABLE THE PERSON
DOCKWORKER AND KIND OF LEARN.
THE GOVERNOR HAS WHAT THE TO
MISCALCULATION BACK GOING TO
PARK. GOVERNOR WILL FOR TALKING
BACK TO THEIR PARTNER. WITH ALL
THE ALL CALIFORNIANS WANT BOX.
EVERY BOXING. WATER THAT THE
MURDERS FORWARD BACK AT. WELL
FOR THE STATE SCRIMMAGE WHEN
UNDERSERVED OF ALL BUSINESS.
YES THE GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA
SMALL THE FOR THE SEVERAL FROM
FIVE HUNDRED MORE DOLLARS THAN
THREE AT THIS POINT. THIS FALL.
AND THEN HOW MAY I HELP YOU AND
SPECIAL FOR WHATEVER RECREATION
CENTER OF PORTO SAN DIEGO
HUNDREDS OF SCHOOL. ALSO
SHORTER THE NEW YORKER THIRD
PART OF HEALTH CORNER WHAT
ABOUT WHAT THAT IS AFFECTING
THE FUNCTION. FOR YEAH.
MOVEMENT THE FORCE THE
TECHNICIAN REGULATORS. IN ORDER
SOLUTION ORIENTED PURCHASE
ISSUES OF ECONOMIC AND BERMAN
CONCERNS. WELL CURRENTLY CAN
YOU KEEP NUMBER COMPETITIVE OF
THE. MORE ON THE- ZERO FOR THE
LONG TERM THE NATURE. OF
AMERICAN AND EXPECTED. JUST
ACCEPT MUCH MORE AND GIVEN
COMPUTER THE PROPER. WAY BACK-
ALSO THIRTEEN ACCOUNT COMMUNITY
THEY ARE NOT. AT A HUNDRED
SUPPLIERS AND THIS CRITICAL
DISTRICTS UPON. DISTORTION OR-
NUMBER STATE REASON TO COME
BACK TO QUALIFY. BUT CONTINUE
SUPPORTING AGRICULTURAL NINE
EXPORTS HELPING GET BACK MARK
ACROSS GLOBE REVERSED THE WORLD
WE'RE AT WORK HARDER NOT MOVE
IN ISHANT AND BERMAN BUT FROM
WAY. OVER THE HAUL WALKING AWAY
FOR ATTENTION BACKGROUND A.
ALSO LOOK FOR OTHER STUDIES AND
RESEARCH. ACTIONS ON THE GROUND.
ON THE PART OF THE SPEECH WE'LL
DISCUSS THE TOPIC IDENTIFY
STATE WHAT PLAN. FOR WE WILL
DISCUSS THE OF THE SPORTS
CHANNELS WE INVEST THAT WELCOME.
WALKER WITH THE OF THE SHIP THE
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED A FEDERAL
COURT OF JUSTICE. FOLLOW THE
MARY OF WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES UP WITH HER PART
IF IT'S OKAY WORKERS
FORECASTERS CONTRACTS. REPORTER
PROPOSAL BEST IN THE COME
GROUND THE FACT THAT. THAT WILL
HELP PRESCRIPTION AFFORDABLE.
FOR DOORS FROM. YEAH THIS IS
WHAT. WHAT THE- BEST KNOWLEDGE
LOCOMOTIVES HARPER SURE OKAY.
THE TRANSITION THERE OR NEAR
ZERO PERSONS WHO PROP UP. BEGIN
WITH WE MUST HONORED IN THE
HOUSE THE BOTTOM THE ONE THE I
LOOK FORWARD. WHAT CORPORATE
INSTANT. FOR THE WALK OF
MEDICATION COOPER. FURTHER
INVESTING AND SAID. WHAT THE
TECHNICIAN ONE SEVEN I THINK
PARKER BIG THAT'S NOT THE
PROBLEM. SACRAMENTO. WE MUST
REDUCE VERY ON THE HIDDEN.
REGIONAL FOR OKAY RANGERS CALL.
THE REGISTRATION. WHAT THE
PRESIDENT OF FOR PRESIDENT OF
YOUR GROUP IS THAT YOU BUT THE
BULK OF THE BARGAINS THE WILL
COVER THE ONE BOTH. WHAT BOB
EXPENSIVE ASSOCIATED PRESS ZERO
WORDS ARE OFFERED. THANK YOU
FOR THE PROGRESS WAS. I THANK
YOU MR MAYOR I PRECIADO YOU'RE
A DISCUSSION OF INFRASTRUCTURE
BECAUSE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT WE BOLSTER THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE FOURTEENTH
FOR STRUCTURE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I JUST TO WANT TO
NOTE THE PRESENCE OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SABRINA IS ABOUT
CERVANTES RIGHT THERE. AND
THEN- ELOISE REYES A MAJORITY
LEADERS HERE AS WELL AND BOTH
OF THEM REPRESENT AREAS WHERE
THERE'S A LOT OF WAREHOUSES SO
THAT MEANS THERE'S A LOT OF
TRUCKS. AND THAT'S ALWAYS A
CONCERN TO THEIR COMMUNITY HOW
THEY'RE IMPACTED BY THIS. THIS
THIS TWO ELEMENTS. I WOULD THAT
WERE GONNA TURN ON TO WE'RE
GONNA GO TO WRONG I DON'T
CONSTANTLY ONLY'S PRESIDENT OF.
I. L. W. INTERNATIONAL
LONGSHORE AND WAREHOUSE UNION
LOCAL THIRTEEN. THAT IS THE
LARGEST UNION- THE REPRESENTS
THE LARGEST NUMBER OF WORKERS
IN THE LA- LONG BEACH PORT
COMPLEX THERE'S ALSO- SIXTY
THREE IS ANOTHER UNION THE
CLERKS AND NINETY FOUR. THE
pPONCE DE LEON YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING I'M IN THE MIDDLE
SAN GONZALEZ MORNING AND THANK
A LITTLE LOUDER. GOOD MORNING
SENATOR CAN IS MEMBER DONALD
MEMBERS OF THE SELECT CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK. YES OKAY I'M
PROMOTE CONSTANTLY ON. I BE
LOCAL EIGHTEEN AND I'M WE HAVE
A LONG TERM RECOVERY FOR AS IT
MIKE DO LOCAL SIXTY THREE HE
WAS LOCAL PRESS DANIEL TO LOOK
NINETY FOUR BECAUSE- REPRESENT
APPROX FIFTY WORKERS IN AMOUNTS
TO SEE FOUR. POINT FOUR OR
ABOUT TO DO OF ALL WEST COAST.
THANK BOOK. COURT COMPLEX
BOXING GROW GOODS AGRO GOOD
STILL INSPIRES EQUIPMENT FROM
NEED THE RIGHT NOW. PERSONAL
PUT THE REQUIREMENT IN EACH
FIRST DRUGS ECONOMIC AND
ACCORDING TO THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES AT. THE SAN PEDRO BAY
PORTS COMPLEX CAN ABOUT LONG
AND LOS MORE CONTAIN PER SHIP
CALL ANY OTHER POOR COP IN THE
THANK YOU 7% OF THE WEST COAST
MARK SHARE. 30% OF OUR NAY MARK
HERE. AT PMA PRESS MCKAY REASON
REAP THAT WE'VE OUT THERE STEP
PROCESS. OF CAL. IF FOR THE
RECORD THIS IN THE MAKE UP OF
OUR WITH NOW W. IN THE- PACIFIC
MERIT TIMES IS OF A COLLECTIVE
WITH FOR THE LOADING AND OF AND
GOODS TO FROM VESSELS THE WEST.
VERY CLOSE THE DELIVERY
RECEIVING A CARGO FROM TERMINAL
A CO LABOR REPLACE COMMITTEE
THE OLD. CARBON BODY THAT
PROCESS. ALL REALLY PRESS TO
THE COMBINE FOR A- TRY. EACH
AREA COULD TAKE A PORT LABOR
THAT COMMITTEE. SO THE
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE- BILL
HERE. IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY
THE PANDEMIC HIT US IN A
INSTINCT CARE AND UNCERTAINTY.
A CO COMMITTEE OR C. O. ART C.
WEEK IT IMMEDIATELY PRESS. TO
REGION AGREEMENT ON PROTOCOL
REALLY TO SEE GUIDE AND MORE
RESEARCH. THOSE OUT BY CAL. THE
COSTA SAID UP A STAR TIME AND
IT ON THIS SHIFT ONE HOUR LATER
FOR THE PURPOSE CLEANING AD
THIS IS. EQUIPMENT AND THE WORK.
CONSISTENTLY THE CITY'S
GUIDELINE. IN DUE TO SOCIAL
BILL PROTOCOL PMA TEMPORARILY
SAYS. ALL TRADE. A COAST
PROTOCOLS MAY THAT THE POOR
THEY WERE REALLY COMMITTEES.
REPORT AND TRACK CASES RELATED
TO THE PANDA. THEY RESTRICT TRY
IMPORTS DELIMITER SPREAD OF THE-
OF THE BUYER. A MAN SOCIAL
PROTOCOL INCLUDE THE MAN. A
COVERINGS SET UP A PAY LEAVE IN
ACCORDANCE WITH THE FCA TO
MEMBERS WEREN'T. AND LOCAL AREA
ALLERGIES INPUT THE AGREED PARK
FROM THE- LOCAL IS. READ LOW
DIMINISH THIS BATCH OF. TO
MINIMIZE A NUMBER LOCAL SIXTY
THREE NINE FOUR ONE TO PHONE
DISPATCH YOU TO SMALLER
MEMBERSHIPS. WE SET UP TO
DISPATCH WHERE TO WORK ACT OF
GANG. WE HAD THIS TEMPERATURE
TEST IN ALL. TO THE TURKS. ON
THE WE SAID GUIDELINES FOR
REPORT AND HOW TO FOR ILLEGAL
THE PORTAL WE SIGNED UP AND-
INDICATING WITH THE LAST DAY. A
POSITIVE OCCURRED IN AREA ON
THAT GERMAN. HELLO CHILD WE
LOCAL THIRTIES THREE FOUR.
ALONG WITH THE EMPLOYER
CONTINUE TO MEET WITH. TO
DISCUSS PRACTICES TO MAKE THE
NECESSARY JUST THAT'S ME A JUST
TO COMBAT THE SPREAD OF THE
VIRUS. DEGREE BACK TO THE BIG.
TRY ANNOUNCED IN AUGUST FIRST
OF TWENTY NINETEEN THAT HE
WOULD IMPOSE A 10% TARIFF ON
THREE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
OF CHINESE IMPORTS IN THE
BEGINNING OF SEPTEMBER ONE.
FOUR DAYS LATER THE CHINESE
COMMERCE MINISTRY ANNOUNCED
THAT CHINA WAS HALTING IMPORTS
ALL AMERICAN AGRICULTURAL
GOODS. WHICH IMMEDIATELY HAD A
DETRIMENTAL IMPACT REPORTS
ECONOMY AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE VIRUS HIT US IN
MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY THE REST
IS HISTORY NOW THERE'S TWO
MAJOR FACTORS THAT PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN THE BEGINNING
OF THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE WAS
THE WARRANT SHERIFF'S. AND THEN
THE OTHER WHICH WAS THEN CALLED
THE WUHAN VIRUS. SO THE
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT THE IMPACTS
OF BOTH WORK HOURS WERE REDUCED
TO A MINIMUM. MANY STEADY
SKILLED LABOR WERE LAID OFF AND
SENT BACK TO WORK THROUGH THE
DISPATCH. THEY'RE IN INCOME.
BOTH PORTED EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS
JEANS ROCK OF LA AND MARIO
CORDERO. OF LONG BEACH WORK IN
CONCERT WITH THE- MAYOR AND
COUNCIL. ASSISTED US IN PP DOES-
OF THE KEY IT DOES SITE FOR ALL
THOSE TWO FREE. THE SAMPEDRO
PORTS. WHAT ARE WE TO ACHIEVE
ACTION FOR THE WORKERS AND ALL
THOSE AND I DO APART AND I
COULD A SPECIAL THANKS MAYOR
GARCIA OF LONG BEACH MY WITHIN
ALL THE LONG TO TELL DEPARTMENT
FOR BEING THE- TO GET MIDDLE IN
THE ARMS OF OUR MEMBERS. IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY TWENTY TRI TO
REPAIR. AT LOS CAR IN SEVEN
COLOR. THE AMOUNTED TO A FIFTY
PER INCREASE IN CARGO FOR THE
PREVIOUS SIX MONTHS NEEDED
ACTION THE CAR TO COME THE
SEARCH INCREASE AS WE ELEVATE
LABOR THE CHAIN IN SKILL
POSITION IN ALL LOCAL. WELL THE
THIRTY NEXT WITH SKILLED. WE
TRY INTO TO THE AND LOCAL AND
THEN BACK TO LABOUR'S. WE THE
NUMBERS A BIT A BIT INTO THE
CASTLE. WE REGISTER COUNTY TO
BE STAY. AND WE ALIBIED.
INDIVIDUALS FOR THE REGISTER
CLASS STATUS TO CLASS THAT.
SUPPLY CHAIN SHORT. THAT NOT
ONLY THE PORT. ACCORDING TO UP
WE CAN TO PAY CARGO. INTO
TWENTY OKAY SEVEN CREE THE PROP.
SO TO EIGHTY TEN RULES FROM THE
TWENTY EIGHT. YEAR WHICH WAS A
YEAR. EVEN THOUGH THE JOURNAL
COMMERCE JAILS CONTAIN REFER TO
US AS SHORT OF LABOR- THERE ARE
THREE OTHER INDUSTRIES ARE
FACTORS INVOLVED IN REGARDS TO
THE BACKLOG OF CONGESTION.
ADMITTED BY THE GLC THE
SHORTAGE OF CHASSIS. RAIL AND
WAREHOUSE ISSUE. DOWN CHASSIS
THE TO J. SEE THE PUBLISHED IN
OCTOBER TWENTY. WELL I WHICH
CAN. LAST ST WELL TIME. MORE
THAN FROM THREE DAYS- EARLIER
THIS. DO SO POINT ONE DAY THIS
WEEK. WAREHOUSE REGARD
WAREHOUSE. ANOTHER ARTICLE OF
THIS BY THE GLC STATES. WELL AS
WAREHOUSES SPREAD WORKERS TO
MORE TO SOCIAL. TAKE WORKERS
TEMP. AND THE SURVEY ARE WHERE
MASKS BROKE. IF HE- AT THE THAT
IT QUOTE IT IN RAIL THERE'S A
PER BY EVER ON SEPT TWENTY
THREE. STATE LETTER SIGNED BY
FEDERAL RAILROAD. ROBERT TO.
AND SERVE CHAIR AT SIR TRUST
BOARD CHAIR AND UP MID READ AS
FOLLOWS RECENTLY HOWEVER WE
HAVE BEEN MADE AWARE OF SERVER
ISSUES INCLUDING MISSED
SWITCHES AND- LOW OR TRADING TO
THE ROOM AVAILABILITY IS. NO IN
ALL. JUST SHORTAGES RAIL ISSUES
WHERE ARE PROTOCOL TO. ARKET TO
THE- AND THE BACK. YES TERRIBLE
AT. GIRLS AT CAPACITY THE
DEMERGE TIME AS DEL THOSE WHO
TO PICK UP THE CAR OKAY TO BEDS.
EXPERIENCE WAIT AND A COUPLE
SELL DIRECT TARGET A GO GET THE
MALE WHEN YOU CLOSE THE SHOP.
SIX BOTTOM IF GET OUT. DELIVER
THE CAN PUT HIM BACK HELLO.
THANK ITS LONGER KIND OF
EXAMPLE WHAT WHAT I IT HITS
VALID. IF YOU. THIS IN THE US
ESPECIALLY. THAT IN THE BIG
MARCH TWO TO THIRTY TWELFTH
FOURTEEN HUNDRED CASES EIGHT
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THREE OF
THOSE WERE POSITIVE THAT'S JUST.
PEOPLE PERCENT RATIO. FROM
JANUARY ONE OF THIS YOU. THE
FABRIC TWELFTH. FIVE HUNDRED
REPORTED CASES THREE HUNDRED.
FIFTY FIVE A POSITIVE. IT'S A
SIXTY PERCENT. IS ELEVEN FROM
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY DECEMBER
SECOND TWENTY TWENTY TWO
JANUARY TWENTY FOURTH IT WAS
ELEVEN FIFTY BACK THAT BEARD
THAT'S NOT RICH OF ONE EVERY
FIVE DAYS. THEY JUST YET TODAY
WE LOST FOREMAN. THE LAST
BATTLE TO THE VIRUS. THIRTEEN
OF IT I WOULD NEED TO BE DONE
HOW DURING THE PANDEMIC WAS
LAST. NUMBER ONE WE'RE
ESSENTIAL RIGHT. FOR THIS IN
THAT DISTURB. I COULD GIVE US
THANKS DELAY PATRICK. WE'RE
GOING TO MILE. AND THE
COMMISSION TO THE STATE NUMBERS.
NUMBER THREE CAN ASSISTANCE IN
THE SUPPLY OF POTOK. WE HAVE
BEEN CLOTH FACIAL. WE IS LIKE
TRIPLE THE SPEED OF WHICH
THAT'S. FOR A BETTER WAY TO
NEED EQUIPMENT THAT AS
ELECTRIFY SPRAYERS WITH UP JUST
A PARTS IF I PUT IT UP FOR
THOUGH. TEST ASSISTANCE SEX
SHIP WERE FOR WORK. YEAH AND
MYSELF. THANK YOU FOR MOVING
CARGO A MISS THIS EPIC TIME
UNCERTAINTY THANK YOU COMMITTEE
AND BETTER FOR YOU TO. THANK
YOU REMOTE IN THANK YOU FOR
BEING A VOICE FOR THE MEN AND
WOMEN ON ON ON THE WATERFRONT
BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT YOU
NEED TO PARTICIPATE THE GREATER
HEALTH OF THE PORT COMMUNITY
MEASURE IT HAS AS A VOICE IN
SACRAMENTO WHICH I THINK IS
VERY WATER THAT RING LABOR I
THINK IT'S A LITTLE. HARDER TO
MAKE SURE OR TALKING TO
CHALLENGES THANK YOU SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT NEXT WE'RE GONNA
GO TO RACHEL MICHELIN PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION SO IF YOU BUY A TV
AN AIR FRYER WHATEVER MAYBE-
THE COMING THROUGH PORTS MOST
LIKELY AND SHE REPRESENTS THOSE
RETAILERS WHO HAVE SO MUCH
BUSINESS. AN INTEREST IN SEEING
THE PORT SUCCESSFUL MOVE GOODS-
AND. MANNER- RACHEL.
RACHEL WE
CANNOT HEAR YOU. STILL WAITING
FOR RACHEL TO SHOW UP ON OUR
SCREEN.
I DON'T. SIR SKINNER
THAT. YEAH WE'RE I'M ABLE TO DO
ANYONE. I DON'T SEE RACHEL
COMING UP ON THE SCREEN. SO NAY
MY TEAM CAN REACH OUT TO HER
BUT WHEN WE MOVED TO DANNY
WANTS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PORT OF OAKLAND. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AT BONNELL- CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES WE CAN WE CAN
SEE IT TOO GOOD JOB. ALL RIGHT.
TRYING TO FIGURE FIGURE OUT THE
A WEBEX- SO I GOT ON SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- TO THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ATTENTION TO THE
PORTS- AND THAT BECAUSE AS YOU
HEARD WE ARE IMPORTANT TO THE
ECONOMY AS WELL AS TO MOVEMENT
OF GOODS AND ALSO EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND AS THE CALL THE
PRICES WILL POINT OUT AND I
WOULD DRESS HERE- FIRST OF ALL
ABOUT THE PORT OF OAKLAND. WE
ARE THE THIRD LARGEST CONTAINER
PORT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND HOWEVER WERE
SOMEWHAT UNIQUE IN THAT THE
PORT OF OAKLAND ALSO RUNS THE
OAKLAND INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT.
AS WELL AS WE- MANAGED NINETEEN
MILES THE OAKLAND WATERFRONT.
TOGETHER WITH OUR- LINES OF
BUSINESS WE REPRESENT ABOUT WE
ARE RESPONSIBLE WE DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY FOR ABOUT EIGHTY
FIVE FIVE THOUSAND JOBS IN THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION. AS
WELL AS IN OUR SEAPORT WE ARE-
VERY MUCH A EXPORT PORTAL. FOR
MUCH OF THE AGRICULTURAL
PRODUCTS FUND CENTRAL VALLEY IN
CALIFORNIA- ALSO WE ARE UNIQUE
IN THAT YOUR SUPPORT IS UNIQUE
IN THAT WE ARE ABOUT 50% IMPORT
AND 50% EXPORT. WHERE IS OUR
COLLEAGUES DOWN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ARE- I WOULD SAY
MOSTLY- IMPORTS SO WE ARE
PROBLEMS THAT- WE ARE VERY
CLOSE CUT TALK CONTACT WITH THE
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY. AS WELL
AS WHETHER- A LOT OF IT
BUSINESSES THAT MAX OUT YOUR
GOODS IN THE CALIFORNIA. FOR
EXAMPLE TELLS LAW HAS ITS PLANT
IN FREMONT AND YOUR PORTABLE
OAKLAND AND THAT THAT WAS A ONE
OF OUR- THEY ABOUT BIG BUSINESS
PARTNERS THEIR SHIPS OUT OF
PORT OF OAKLAND EXPORTS. SO IT
IS A THEREFORE DEPLORABLE
CRIMES TRIAL POSITION B. THE
PORTAL BUT MIKE TO A BUSINESS A.
SHIP'S DATA DOES BUSINESS ASIA.
ARE TODAY THEME IS A- VISIT IN
ACTION. BOSTON TRIES- I THINK-
IT IS FOR TO SAY THAT THE WITH
TEST. ALL OF US. AND- MAKE SURE
THE SHOWS. THAT WOULD YOU KNOW
THE GOAL GETS TOP TOUGH GET
GOING AND THAT ALSO SHOWS HOW
WELL WE CAN DO BUT ALSO SHOWS
SOME WEAKNESS IS BEING OUR
OPERATIONS HI THIS THIS TIME
THAT WHEN THE PEOPLE MOST
REPAIRED AND IT DID NOT WORK SO
THE MOST UP TO BROWN RUNNING.
SHOWS IT'S A ABILITY TO HANDLE
THE PRICES. ARE FOR ME AND FOR
THE PORT OF OAKLAND FOR THE
EMPLOYEES OF THE PORT THE CALL
THE CRISIS HIT US- WENT WITH
THE GRAPHIC PRINCESS CRUISE
SHIP PULLED UP AT THE PORT OF
OAKLAND AND WE REALIZED THAT
THAT WAS EVEN THAT WAS A TIE IN
MARCH OF LAST YEAR. WHEN PEOPLE
DIDN'T REALLY QUITE KNOW WHAT
THIS COAT COVERT VIRUS WAS
THERE WAS A LOT OF FEAR. I IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE GETTING OFF THE
CRUISE SHIP WHAT ARE THEY GOING
TO DO ARE THEY GONNA TRANSIT
VIRUS AND POWER GOING TO IT
THESE PEOPLE TO HOW MUCH
CORENTIN DO WE NEED SO BUT
NONETHELESS THE PORTABLE
BECAUSE STEPPED UP TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- FACILITATES THE
FACILITATOR SACRAMENTO AND
RELIEF EFFORTS. TO DISEMBARK
THE PASSENGERS AND HELP PROVIDE
MEDICAL SCREENING. ASSISTANCE
FOR THOSE COMING ASHORE. I
THINK IS A- IN ADDITION TO THE
SEAPORT- EMPTY THE- COULD. OUT
OF THE WAY- MAKING SURE P. ARE
ABLE TO GET OFF THE BOAT AND
SHIP ONTO THE GROUND BECAUSE
THE PORT OF OAKLAND IS NOT A
CRUISE SHIP TERMINAL. THERE
REALLY IS NO STAIRS OR STEPS
FOR PEOPLE TO GET OFF SHIPS- TO
THE SEAPORT NOW AS WE SET UP IN
WITHIN THE SPACE OF TWO DAYS-
BUT EQUALLY IMPORTANT BUT
PROBABLY LESS RECOGNIZED WAS
THE RANA PLAZA EFFORT OF OUR-
AVIATION STAFF AT THE OAKLAND.
AIRPORT WHO DIRECTED TO
TRANSPORT PASSENGERS INCLUDE
THROUGHOUT THE AIRPORT IN ORDER
TO GET THEM HOME TO LOCATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE AMERICAN AROUND
THE ORLD. IT WAS NO SMALL
DOING. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD
FLIGHTS- THAT ARE NOT
SCHEDULED. TO COORDINATE WITH
THE DISEMBARKATION OF THE
PASSENGERS OFF THE CRUISE SHIP
IN ORDER TO FLY THEM HOME. TO
VARIOUS PLACES- WHETHER THEY
NEED TO BE POINTING WHEN THEY
GET THERE OR NOT AND A- LOT OF
THE CREW HAD TO BE FLOWN BACK
TO ASIA- SO THERE WAS A LOT OF-
BOTH CAPACITORS. LANDING
CALIFORNIA AROUNDTHE UNITED
STATES. BUT AS WELL AS AROUND
THE WORLD. I THINK THE COUPLE
OF HOURS ALSO. US IN TURN OR
MERGE WHICH- TO BE. FOR OUR- AS
WELL- THE PORT OF OAKLAND
BECAUSE OF ITS CONNECTIONS IT
WITH THE INTERNATIONAL TO PLY
CHIANG. WERE ABLE TO IS. SECURE
ON MASKS. AS YOU REMEMBER BACK
IN MARCH- MASKS WASN'T WEARING
SHORT SUPPLY. ND SO WE WERE
ABLE TO GO THROUGH OUR NETWORK
TO GET MASKS NOT ONLY FOR ALL
EMPLOYEES. OF FOR OUR FOLKS TO
WORKING OUT OF THE LONG SHORT A
SECTOR AS WELL AS THAT PEOPLE
WORKING. AROUND THE CHAD
LOGISTICS CHAIN. I THINK IS.
DAMAGE IT IS DEMONSTRATED THAT
THE PORTS THE INVITATION TO
IMPORTANCE OF COMMERCE AS WELL
AS TO- TO THE JOBS. THAT WE ARE
A ESSENTIAL EMERGENCY RESPONSE
FACILITY. AS WE DEMONSTRATED.
NOW THAT THAT'S MOVE ON TO- IN
TERMS OF THAT WHAT'S GOING ON
IN TERMS THE CARGO I'VE HEARD
MUCH ABOUT LOS ANGELES LONG
BEACH THE CONGESTION THAT'S
HAPPENING THERE. ARE WE ARE
HAPPY THAT THE PORT OF OAKLAND
IS ABLE TO- STEP AGAIN STEP UP
AGAIN TO RELIEVE SOME OF THAT
PRESSURE IN ITS SUPPLY HAIN. I
WANTED IT- SORT OF THREE TO
PANDEMIC BOB THIS IS THAT IS
BEING REVEALED ITSELF IS THAT A
LOT OF THEIR SHIPMENTS OF GOODS
SOMETIMES POST ON THE SHIP ASIA
BOSU LOS ANGELES LONG BEACH
FIRST AS THE FIRST PORT OF CALL
AND THEY UNLOAD THEIR CARGO
THERE AND THEY DO COME BACK TO
OAKLAND AS A SECOND PORT OF
CALL IN ORDER TO FOLLOW THIS
THE GOODS THERE ARE DESTINED
FOR NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
ALSO NEVADA IN ENGLAND TO- I
HAVEN'T. TO- TO INTERN IN THE
DESTINEE TO RAIL. AND ALSO THE
EXPORTERS THEN GET TO. LOAD
THEIR CARGO DESTINED FOR ASIA.
HOWEVER WHAT'S HAPPENED HOWEVER
IS THAT SINCE THERE'S
CONGESTION LONG BEACH AND LOS
ANGELES- THESE FOLKS WHO ARE
WAITING TO EAT. LOADED UNLOAD
THEIR GOODS IN OAKLAND HAVE TO
WAIT FOR THE TIMES THAT ARE DIG
BEING DETAINED IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PORTS IN ORDER TO
MAKE THE SECOND PORT OF CALL.
IN OAKLAND. I THINK THE
REALIZATION AND- DO THIS
CRISIS. IS THAT HEY THAT
DOESN'T QUITE MAKE SENSE IN
ORDER TO RELIEVE THE CONGESTION
OAKLAND. WHY DON'T SOMEBODY
SHIP SIMPLY COME TO OPEN FIRST
AS THE FIRST PORT OF CALL IN
ORDER TO RECEIVE THE EXPORT
GOODS ARE WAITING AT THE PORT.
OF OAKLAND AND ALSO TO. OFFLOAD
GOODS THAT THE FOLKS KNOW
CONSUMERS ARE WAITING FOR IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. SO INDEED-
THIS. JUST THIS MONTH. WHAT ARE
THE SHIPPING LINES ANNOUNCED
THAT THEY WILL BE MAKING A
FIRST PORT OF CALL TO THE
PORTABLE CLICKED. NOW THAT'S
PART OF THE PROBLEM PUBLIC
TRUST PART OF THE SOLUTION. THE
SECOND AS YOU REALIZE THE
LOGISTICS CHANGE NOT SHIPS WAS
ALSO TRUCKS TRAINS AND BEING
ABLE TO GET THESE GOODS IN AND
OUT OF THE GOOD PARTS QUICKLY-
THAT IS ALSO CAUSING SOME
CONGESTION AS WELL. AND
THEREFORE I THINK ARE REAL BILL
TO STEP UP IN ORDER TO RECEIVE
THOSE GOODS AND SHIPPED THEM
INTO THE INLAND DESTINATIONS
AND WAREHOUSES ARE AVAILABLE
BOTH AT THE PORT OF OAKLAND AND
IN NORFOLK CALIFORNIA
DESTINATIONS AS TRACY. SO I
THINK WHAT THIS IS REVEALED
HOWEVER. IS THAT THERE NEEDS TO
BE A COORDINATED APPROACH. TO
PLAN FOR GOODS MOVEMENT AND
THEY JUST PICKED IN CALIFORNIA-
THE WAY WE'RE DOING IT NOW IS
THAT THE FOR THE FOR THE
OPERATING FAIRLY INDEPENDENTLY.
AND IS SOMETIMES WERE IN
COMPETITION SOMETIMES WE
COOPERATE BUT THESE LOGISTIC
CHAINS ARE AT THE MERCY OF
WORSHIPS CHOOSE THE GOAL AND
WHERE DO YOU THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE THE FASTEST. THEREFORE I
THINK THIS CRISIS REVEALED IS
THAT WE DO NEED A CALIFORNIA
PORTS PLAN LOGISTICS PLAN TO
MAKE SURE THE GOODS FLOW WHERE
THEY NEED TO BE. THE MOST
EFFICIENTLY RATHER THAN WAIT
FOR SIMPLY A CRISIS THAT
HAPPENED TO SHOW IT TO US. AT
AND THAT IS THAT SORT OF THE
LESSONS THAT WE'RE LEARNING
FROM HERE AND ALSO YOU WILL
HEAR THAT PROBABLY FROM THE
TESTIMONY FROM- LATER SPEAKERS.
THAT THE STATE'S INVESTMENT IN
THE FACILITIES THE PORTS
LARGELY DEPENDS ON THE FORTUNES
OF THE IT EACH INDIVIDUAL
PORTS. WE DON'T GET TAX DOLLARS
WERE OPERATIONS WE SCAN PEOPLE
GRANTS FIRST FACILITIES FROM
THE STATE BUT MOST OF OUR
INCOME INVESTMENTS I MADE FOR
THE BUSINESSES THAT WE MAKE. I
THAT IS SOMEWHAT UNUSUAL IN THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE YOU FEEL
COULD GO AROUND THE COUNTRY.
THE COMPETITORS THAT THAT WE
FACE IN CALIFORNIA OUR PORTS IN
EAST COAST AND SOUTH COAST
VIRGINIA GEORGIA AND HOUSTON
TEXAS THE WALLS IN CANADA IN
VANCOUVER BRITISH COLUMBIA. OUR
SHARE OF THE MARKET IN THE
WORLD TODAY IN THE UNITED
STATES CARGO HAS DROPPED FROM
OVER 50% TO DOWN TO NOW 40% WHY
BECAUSE THESE OTHER PORTS ARE
COMPETING BETTER THAN WE ARE IN
TERMS OF RECEIVING CARGO. PART
OF THE REASON YOU'LL SEE. AS
YOU LOOK INTO THE NUMBERS IS
THAT THE STATE'S IN THOSE OTHER
STATES THE STATE GOVERNMENT IN
THOSE OTHER STATE PORTS SUPPORT.
AND INVEST HEAVILY INTO THE
PORTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
DISK CHAINS ARE COORDINATED
STATEWIDE THE INVESTMENT VERY
MADE A STATEWIDE FASHION. I AM
ADVOCATING AND I THINK YOU WILL
HEAR FROM OTHERS AT THE STATE.
AND WE APPRECIATE THIS THIS
THIS- THIS HEARING IS A GOOD
START TO GET THE STATE TO THINK
ABOUT A STATEWIDE COORDINATED
EFFORT BOTH IN TERMS OF
LOGISTICS EFFICIENCY AND IN
TERMS TO ENVIRONMENTAL
INVESTMENT ARE YOU HERE FOR A
LATER PANEL. I'LL STOP THERE
AND I REALLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I'M OPEN TO QUESTIONS
I GUESS IF THERE'S ANY. THANK
YOU MR ONE WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO ORIGINAL MICHELIN I
BELIEVE SHE'S ON THE PHONE SHE
IS PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION RACHEL. I
CAN HEAR YOU. I DON'T. HEARING
ROOMS. THANK YOU TO HEAR ME WE
CAN HEAR YOU. ARE YOU GUYS
SORRY THANK YOU IS IT JUST KIND
OF OUR PROGRAMS BROWN THE
REALITY IS THAT I AM WELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
CHAIRED THE MEMBERS. THANK YOU
LIVE OUR LIVES IN A PRE
INDUSTRIAL MANNER WE DON'T GROW
OUR OWN. BAKER I'M CLOSE
PROVIDER OF MEDICAL CURES WE
ALL DEPEND ON A WELL BACKED UP
BY CHIANG TO ENSURE WE HAVE THE
PRODUCT DELIVERY TRUCK YOU NEED
TO BE. SICK IF THEY EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT DURING THE GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. BUT WHY CHALLENGES
THEIR BUSINESSES FACE IN TERMS
OF OUR SUPPLY. CHAIN THAT GREW
DURING PROGRAM. NUMBER ONE I'M
CERTAIN. SAID HATES CENTER. AND
CO. OVER ABOUT A THIRD KEY
DROUGHT THE SUPPLY CHAIN. THE
ENTIRE. EFFORTS IS UNDER STRESS.
AND BECAUSE OF THE CODE NINE
CLASS. IT'S BEEN. ISSUE ENTIRE.
THAT WAS TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
THE SUPPLY CHAIN TOGETHER HELLO.
SHOPPERS EFFICIENCY. OUR
STRATEGY SHOULD FOCUS ON FUTURE.
SUNDAY WE NEED PASSED NAY. I'VE
CHANGING WALDRON TO BUILD. WHAT
COMPLY WITH PUT FORTH BY AND
APPOINTED LEADERS. BECOME EVEN
MORE CHALLENGING AT THE LACK OF
A APPOINTED HAVE PASSED NEW
RIGHT THAT NAME OF KOBE MOST.
IS THE ORDER AND THEN YOU CAN
CON CONTRADICTED JOHN AS A VERY
REGULAR BODY YOU'RE NOT WITH
OTHER AGENCIES MAKING IT CLOSE
TO IMPOSSIBLE FOR BUSINESSES TO
COMPLY IN CALIFORNIA'S COMPLEX.
REGULATORY OPEN BACK. BACKING
WE KNOW THE KEY TO GETTING HOW
THE BACK ON TRACK IS A QUICK.
AND AFTER BACK OUT THAT
INCLUDES OUR SUPPLY CHAIN
PARTNERS CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
STRONGLY SUPPORT AN EXPECTED.
PLANT THE STATE GUARD THAT THE
SUPPLY CHAIN IS NOT DISTRACTED
DUE TO KOBE. CALIFORNIA SUPPLY
CHAIN IS CO DEPENDENT WE NEED
EVERY PART OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN
STRONG AND HEALTHY TO ENSURE WE
CAN COMPLETE CALLED LOCALLY.
BUT THAT'S BEEN A CHALLENGE AS
THE WORLD PERTAINING TO THE
COVERS BACK THREE THREE TO
CHANGE DALY. CHERRY RETAIL
PHARMACY STAND READY TO ASSIST
OUR SUPPLY CHAIN PARTNERS
SHOULD THEY GET ACCESS TO THE
VACCINE TO ENSURE THOSE SHOTS
ARE GIVEN TO OUR FRONT. LINE
SUPPLY CHAIN WORKERS. THESE ARE
CATS JOHN. AND RETAILERS YOU X.
THE BUDGET BY TO GET WITH THAT
ON THEIR OWN WE TO BE A ACTIVE.
AND FINING THE WE THAT STABLE
CAL THE CHAIN NOW I SOLIDIFY
TWO YEARS CURRENT. HOW DO WE DO
THAT. BETTER WE NEED TO GET RID
OF THE SILOS THAT WE WORK WITH
BANK BUSINESS GOVERNMENT AND
OUR BY BODY NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER UNIK KIDDING FAITH AND
FIND STRATEGIES TO ACHIEVE
ADVICE AND REGULAR BOWL HELLO
POLICY LEADERS ASKED TO SOME OF
THE WHY MY IN THE WAR LENNIX TO
BUT YOU INNOVATION THEY SHOULD
USE THAT WE BY BRINGING AND
WORK FOR BACK AT YOU REGULATE.
AND LIFT TO ALTERNATIVE IDEAS
ON HOW TO ACHIEVE GOALS ARE
UNITED PLANTER CALIFORNIA'S.
CHAIN HELLO IS THE FIFTH
LARGEST. BECAUSE OF OUR POOR
INTO CHAIN. TAKE THAT AWAY AND-
BLUE ITS- STANDING. EXPERIENCE
FROM INCOURT INCOME. THE
FLIGHT HAS IT'S NOT PRIORITIZE
BY A POLICY. AND INSTEAD OF
PROVIDING INFECTION AND
OPPORTUNITIES TO BE MORE
COMPETITIVE ON THE WORLD STAGE
EIGHT FIVE ARTICLES IN THE WAY
THAT GAMBHIR INNOVATION AND PUT
THE FUTURE OF OUR COURT SYSTEM
IN JEOPARDY. WE CANNOT LET THIS
HAPPEN WE NEED TO DO BETTER
BETTER FAR SUPPLY CHAIN. BETTER
FOR OUR ECONOMY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY BETTER FOR THE
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE PART OF THE
SUPPLY CHAIN NETWORK. BUT YOU
WORK TOGETHER ON A STRATEGY TO
HIT ENVIRONMENTAL TARGETS.
ENSURE EMPLOYEES HAVE ACCESS TO
BACKSEAT MPP AND FOCUS ON
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SO WE'RE
READY TO TAKE ON. THE
LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES OF
TOMORROW. AND VALUES VOICE OF
BUSINESS IN REGULAR PROCESS.
OCT IN A REGULAR KLEIN THAT IS
BEAUTIFUL BEING AGAINST
INNOVATION IT MORE AND IN HEY
BROTHER WORKING COLLABORATIVE
ADJUSTING LOCAL. HOW BUDGET FIX
THAT THAT THIS WHICH IS EVEN
APPARENT NOW DO I KOBE. WE WANT
TO WORK WITH MY AND NEW WASTE
THE CARVER. THE FIRST GOVERNOR
AND WE ARE ARE LACKING IN. TO
HELP BUT STILL THE COME WITH.
ACROSS THE STATE THE SUPPLY
CHAIN KEPT TRACK ALONG CHANGE
NOT OF CALIBER BUT THE NATURE
HAS. MEDICAID TOILET PAPER THE
PRICE IN OTHER NEWS ITEMS. WE
NEED TO TOGETHER TO ENSURE OUR
GOOD MARKET WITH STRONG. AND WE
DO NOT IN A WORD OF SHARE. AND
OF THE CARGO WEEK OUR TOP OUR
FOR IN THE JUST COMMUNITY AND I
LOOK TO OUR CALL WORK ON
ENSURING OUR BY CHAIN CAN CAN
OUR- AND PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
PRODUCT THE CALIFORNIA AND
BEYOND. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY AND PLEASE
KNOW THE CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION HERE'S TO PARTNER
WITH ALL OF YOU TO ENSURE THAT
THIS MOVEMENT IN OUR STATE
REMAINS AS STRONG. GLOBAL
LEADER. THANK YOU MISTER INTO
YOU FOR THE ASK THAT WE- INSURE
THE BEST HAS A VOICE IN THE
PROCESS BE REGULATORY OR
OTHERWISE BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT. SO I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE- THAT
POINT WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GO ON TO ELAINE FORMS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PORT OF SAN
FRANCISCO ELAINE FORBES.
MORNING JOURNAL CAN YOU HEAR ME
THIS WEEKEND THANK YOU UP
EXCELLENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
JOURNAL MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE I MEANING WORKS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE PORT
OF SAN FRANCISCO. AND I'M GOING
TO GIVE YOU AN UPDATE ON HOW
COLD IT HAS IMPACTED THE PORT
OF SAN FRANCISCO THE PORT MANN
JUST SEVEN AND A HALF MILES OF
THE FRONTRUNNER LINE FROM
FISHERMAN'S WHARF TO HERON'S
HEAD PARK. AND WE HOST SOME OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT VISITOR
SERVING RESOURCES IN THE BAY
AREA WE SUPPORT MARITIME
COMMERCE WE MAINTAIN OPEN
SPACES AND PARKS ACCESS TO THE
BAY AND IMPORTANTLY WE LEASE
OUR SPACES TO ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED BUSINESSES THAT WELCOME
COUNTLESS VISITORS. LOCALLY
REGIONALLY AND FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY. THIS
ALL CONTRIBUTES TO THE ECONOMY
OF SAN FRANCISCO AND OF COURSE
TO OUR STATE ECONOMY. WE ALSO
WORK TO ADVANCE PUBLIC PRIVATE
DEVELOPMENT PARTNERSHIPS ON
SURPLUS PORT LANDS TO BUILD
MORE NEW NEIGHBORHOODS- THAT
SUPPORT OUR HOUSING SHORTAGE
AFFORDABILITY. DIVERSITY AND
OTHER IMPORTANT GOALS FOR OUR
LANDS. NOW TO WHAT CO THAT HAS
MANAGED TO THE PORT OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND YOU'VE HEARD A
LOT ABOUT GOODS MOVEMENT TODAY
AND I'M GOING TO SPEAK IS A
BOUTIQUE PORT IS MORE IN THE
BUSINESS OF PASSENGER MOVING-
AND SHARE SIMILARITIES WITH
PORT OF SAN DIEGO AND SOME OF
THE OTHER. SPORTS ALONG THE
STATE. WE HAVE MANY FACILITIES
IN TENANTS THAT ARE CLOSED OR
NEARLY CLOSED TO THE PANDEMIC
AND THE HEALTH WORKERS THAT
HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO KEEP. OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE. WE HAVE
POTENTIALLY VERY PROFOUND
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES FROM THIS
DECLINE IN REVENUE AND FROM THE
SHORE- THE SHEDDING. NUMEROUS
NUMEROUS FOR BUSINESSES AND
TENDENCIES WHICH I'LL DISCUSS
IN MY REMARKS TODAY BUT FIRST I
WANT TO SPEAK TO RESILIENCE AND
THE IMPORTANT ROLE THAT PORTS
HAVE PLAYED IN THE COVERT
RESPONSE. BECAUSE FIRST AND
FOREMOST FOR THE PORT OF SAN
FRANCISCO WHAT. IT MEANT FOR US
WAS RESPONDING TO THE NEEDS OF
OUR CITY IN NEED- WE QUICKLY
PIVOTED A THIRTEEN ACRE SITE OF
OURS PEERS THIRTY THIRTY TWO
FROM CONSUMER PARKING. COMMUTER
PARKING SORRY- ONTO A TESTING
SITE THAT HAS SERVED HIGH
VOLUME TESTING THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC. WE TRANSFORMED
INDUSTRIAL LAYDOWN SPACE AND
OUR SOUTHERN WATERFRONT- IN ON
OUR MARINE FACILITY I TO
SHELTER HOMELESS- IN TRAILERS
FROM THE BACK LANDS THOSE
MARINE TERMINALS ARE PEERS
NINETY FOUR NINETY SIX. WE'VE
WELCOMED PP DISTRIBUTION AND
STORAGE WE HAVE A FOOD PANTRY
ON OUR LAND AND WE HAVE
DEDICATED THOUSANDS OF HOURS OF
PORT STAFF TIME FROM OUR CRAFTS
FOR MORE LOGISTICS TEAM PROJECT
MANAGERS COMMUNICATIONS EXPERTS
REALLY PORT SPECIALTIES. ALL
THE WHILE THE PORT OF SAN
FRANCISCO HAS WORKED HARD TO
PROTECT OUR PROPERTY AND
PROTECT OUR TENANTS THROUGH
THIS REALLY UNPRECEDENTED.
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. WE ON- A
PROSPERITY MODEL WITH OUR
TENANTS A SHARED. MY TO HELP
OUR CAN WHETHER STORM. THOSE
THAT AND CAN BE PROUD. ON THE
OTHER SIDE OF THIS PANDEMIC
WE'VE OFFERED TEN- RENT RELIEF
SPECIFIC RENT RELIEF FOR
MARITIME TENANTS. OF FORMER
MISSION OF RETAIL TENANTS WHICH
ARE CLOSED OR NEARLY CLOSED AND
FOR NONPROFIT SMALL BUSINESSES
ARTISTS. WITH THE GOAL OF
VIBRANCY AND DIVERSITY FIRE
WATERFRONT. SO NOW I'M GOING TO
TURN TO THE ECONOMIC CONDITIONS
OF THE PORT OF SAN FRANCISCO IS
A AS IT RELATES TO THIS
PANDEMIC SO WE ARE SUFFERING.
ONE ONCE IN A LIFETIME
REDUCTION IN OUR REVENUES WE
HAVEN'T SEEN THIS TYPE OF
REVENUE. I DECLINE- IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT OR IN ANY OTHER
TIME AND THIS IS REALLY
ACTIVITY FROM CRUISE RESTAURANT
TOURIST ATTRACTIONS AND PARKING
WHICH IS SIGNIFICANTLY DROPPED
OFF OR IN SOME CASES STOP
ENTIRELY. WE ARE SO HEAVILY
DEPENDENT ON TOURISM AND
HOSPITALITY AND OUR WATERFRONT
IT'S WHERE. WE EXPECT TO
RECOVER. RIGHT NOW WE ARE
PRETTY. THAT WE DON'T EXPECT A
FULL RECOVERY OF TOURISM UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE OR PERHAPS
BEYOND DEPENDING ON CONSUMER
BEHAVIORS AND HOW QUICKLY THIS
VIRUS IS- HANDLED AND BEHIND US
AS IT RELATES TO VACCINATIONS.
ADDITIONAL CARGO ROBEL-
AUTOMOTIVE SWITCHES EXPORT HAS
BEEN ACTUALLY STRONG AND NOT
MUCH HASN'T SEEN MUCH IMPACT
FROM THE PANDEMIC LUCKILY FOR
US- BUT BECAUSE OF THE VIRUS
OUR REVENUES HAVE FALLEN 50% IN
THE CURRENT YEAR THAT SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND WE PREDICT
SIXTY FIVE MILLION AND THE NEXT
TWO YEARS- FROM THESE DECLINES
IN ECONOMIC SHOCKS AND THIS IS
ON A BUDGET OF ONLY A HUNDRED
AND TE MILLION DOLLARS SO WE
ARE A SMALL BUT MIGHTY
ORGANIZATION. WITH AT FOUR
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLAR BALANCE SHEET SO IT'S
REALLY SUBSTANTIAL AND DEEP
IMPACTS. AS OUR TO ILLUSTRATE
THIS POINT AND THE CITY'S
GENERAL FUND WE'RE PREDICTING A
4% DECLINE IN THE FOUR YEAR
PROJECTION PERIOD FOR THE COURT
WE'RE LOOKING AT 28% DECLINE
INVOLVING HIM. 30% 33% OF OUR
STAFF IS AN ARMY INSIDE THE
CRAFTS THAT MAINTAIN OUR
FACILITIES FOR THE VALUE AND
BENEFITS OF OUR TORRANCE AND
OUR VISITORS AND TO. BUILD A
VERY BEAUTIFUL WELCOMING AND
SAFE HARBOR. TO DATE THE COURT
IS REALLY THE STRATEGIES THAT
DEPLETE OUR SAVINGS AND OUR
CAPITAL PROGRAM BUT THIS CANNOT
BE SUSTAINED OTHERWISE WE WILL
HAVE TO SHATTER OTHER
FACILITIES AND WE WILL NOT BE.
POSITION TO WELCOME BACK
VISITORS AND BE. PART OF THE
STATE'S ECONOMIC RECOVERY
ADDING TO ITS RECOVERY INSTEAD
WE WOULD BE A DEFICIT IF WE
WERE TO CUT AS EXTREMELY AS THE
REVENUE- YEAH DEBT AND DECLINE
FROM THE VIRUS IS CAUSING AND
THIS IS ALL OF THE REASONS THAT
I AM VERY VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
PORTS BEING. NOT PASSED OVER
THIS TIME IN THE FEDERAL RELIEF
BILL AND THROUGH THE STATE IT
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT
PORT STAND BY OUR COMMUNITIES
AND ADDS VALUE TO ECONOMIC
RECOVERY- BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
WE WELCOME TO TWENTY FOUR
MILLION VISITORS PER YEAR
HUGELY ECONOMICALLY IMPACTFUL
SHRUM FISHERMAN'S WHARF TO
ORACLE PARK TO THE
EXPLORATORIUM. WE ARE LEADING
THE WAY AND RESILIENCY. THIS
CONFERENCE IS ABOUT RESILIENCE
C. OR C. LAW RISE ADDRESS. RISK
THIS IS A VERY. PROGRAM AT HAVE
LOCALS. IN TOOK FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE MILLION AT THE- AS
WELL AS FEDERAL SUPPORT TO LOOK
AT HOW TO PROTECT URBAN
SHORELINES FROM FLOOD. AND
EARTHQUAKE RISK WE MUST
CONTINUE THIS PROGRAM NOT ONLY
FOR THE VALUE OF SAN FRANCISCO
BUT OTHER URBAN PORTS IN THE
STATE SB ON. CRUISE SHIPS OF
COURSE WELCOME THOUSANDS OF
VISITORS AND GENERATE. NUMEROUS.
VALUE TO THE CITY. OUR TENANTS
ARE CRITICAL LINK AND REGIONAL
MARITIME INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL
OUR TUG OPERATIONS SUPPORT
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF CARGO AS
IT ENTERS THE MARY MARCH SO FOR
ALL OF THESE REASONS. I WILL
CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
FEDERAL AND STATE SUPPORT AND
RELIEF FUNDING TO CONDITION
PORTS TO WEATHER AND RECOVER
THE STORM AND BE PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT FOR COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRIAL ACTIVITIES MARITIME
USES CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
TOURIST ECONOMY WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND ENVIRONMENTAL
AND REMEDIATION ARE REALLY
ESSENTIAL TOOLS NEEDED TO HELP
WORKERS BUSINESSES. AND LOCAL
RESIDENTS RECOVER POST CODE
NINETEEN I THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE SELECT COMMITTEE TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I THANK
YOU MISS FORBES EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PORT OF SAN
FRANCISCO WE'RE NOW GOING TO
TURN DOOR. OUR NEXT PANEL THE
WILL JUST HAVE QUESTIONS AT THE
END THERE I DO WANNA KNOW THE
PRESENCE OF A SIMILAR MIKE
GIPSON. WHICH SHARES I GUESS
WHAT I'M PROBABLY THE NORTHERN
PART OF MY DISTRICT HE HAS- A%
LOT OF THE PORT COMPLEX I GUESS
IS THE BEST WAY TO PUT IT. LOT
OF GOODS MOVING. ACT A- IN HIS.
AS WELL PRESENCE TODAY SO YOU
MR GIBSON- WILL MOVE ON TO OUR
GREEN PORTS AND THE STATEWIDE
ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS OUR SECOND
PANEL WILL DISCUSS THE
INDUSTRY'S WORK TO MEET. OUR
STATEWIDE ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
AND THE SUPPORT THEY NEED FROM
STATE LEADERS. THESE PANELS
WILL HAVE NO MORE THAN FIVE
MINUTES AGAIN WE WILL HOLD
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS TO THE
END. AND AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
IF IT'S GREE. IT'S INNOVATIVE
AND IT'S CUTTING EDGE IT'S
HAPPENING IN THE PORTS. IN AN
EFFORT TO CUT GREENHOUSE GASES
EMISSIONS ECCENTRIC IT HAPPENED
IN THE PORTS THAT'S WHERE IT'S
ALL HAPPENING AT LEAST IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA A LOT GOING
ON IN THE PORTS. FIRST WE'LL
HEAR FROM BILL VAN AMBURG
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF CAL
START MISTER VAN AMBURG. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF IT AND THAT
SUCH A PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU
TO TODAY. I AM BUILDING AT
BURKE EXEC VP AT CAL STARTED WE
ARE A CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY ORGANIZATION. OF MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
COMPANIES WERE BASED IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WE DO WORK A
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY
ON THESE. AND I DO HAVE SOME
SLIDES THAT I WILL SHARE WITH
YOU HERE TODAY. HOW TO GIVE YOU
A SENSE OF- WHERE THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS GOING BECAUSE I
THINK EVEN AS WE'RE STRUGGLING
WITH THE PANDEMIC- AND OTHER
ISSUES AND HOPEFULLY. WELL
LET'S NOT THE SCREEN I WANTED
TO SHARE IS IT. TRY THAT AGAIN
I EVEN AS WE STRUGGLE WITH THE
PANDEMIC- RIGHT NOW WE ARE ALSO
FACING A TREMENDOUS TIME TO
MOVE FORWARD THE GREEN
TECHNOLOGY. THAT NOT ONLY WE
NEED FOR OUR URBAN RESIDENTS
WHO WERE REALLY LOOKING FOR
MORE CLARITY IN THEIR ERROR BUT
ALSO ON CLIMATE CHANGE AND
GREATER. COMPETITIVENESS AND
EFFICIENCY IN OUR WHOLE SUPPLY
CHAIN SO IT ISN'T AN X. REALLY
EXCEEDINGLY EXCITING TIME NOW
WE MANAGE A NUMBER OF THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS. IN THE
STATE THE H. FIP PROGRAM FOR
TRUCKS AND BUSES TO BUY DOWN
THEIR COSTS AND THE CLEAN OFF
ROAD EQUIPMENT PROGRAM. WHICH
HELPS FOR- EQUIPMENT AT THE
PORTS IN GOODS MOVEMENT THESE
ARE THE TYPES OF PROGRAMS THAT
WE REALLY NEED THE STATE TO
FURTHER EXPAND AND GROW TO HELP
OUR PORTS- ANDOTHERS ACHIEVE
THE ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS WE
HAVE. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT'S
REALLY INTERESTING IS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S GOALS THE ADVANCE
CLEAN TRUCK RULES ARE THAT ARE
PUSHING TOWARDS GREATER CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ZERO EMISSION. ARE
ACTUALLY BEING ADOPTED NOT ONLY
BY OTHER REGIONS OF THE UNITED
STATES ABOUT THERE BEING
ADOPTED BY OTHER NATIONS OF THE
WORLD AND AS WE REALLY START TO
SEE THIS- THIS CHANGE GOING ON
IT'S SENDING A CLEAR SIGNAL TO
INDUSTRY OF WERE INVESTMENTS
NEED TO GO THESE ONLINE
POLICIES. REALLY. A PROVIDE
TREMENDOUS STRENGTH. TO AND ALL
HOPEFULLY THIS IS A CHANCE TO
GIVE YOU SOME OF. THESE
PICTURES HERE WHAT WE'RE
TALKING THIS REALLY SENSE A
SIGNAL TO INDUSTRY. OF WHAT
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
AND HELPS THEM FURTHER ALIGN
THEIR BEST MONTH SO THAT THEY
CAN MEET THE NEEDS OF THESE
GOALS AS WE GO FORWARD- NOW
WHERE IS THE TECHNOLOGY AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS I
WOULD WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
TODAY AS A SENSE OF WHAT IS THE
REALITY. WHAT'S MOVING FORWARD
AND CAN WE MAKE THESE
TECHNOLOGIES MOVE FORWARD ON
THE PACE THAT WE WANT. SO I
THINK- FIRST OF ALL. YOU CAN
SEE A LIGHT DUTY SPACE OR THE-
LOWER END OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY THE DELIVERY TRUCKS
THERE'S TREMENDOUS CHANGE GOING
ON BUT THIS IS ACTUALLY ALSO
MOVING INTO. WHAT WE NOW VIEW
AS THE HEAVIEST APPLICATIONS IN
THE DRAYAGE APPLICATIONS ALL OF
THESE PLATFORMS THAT YOU SEE
HERE IS OR ACTUALLY IN EARLY
PRODUCTION. OR ABOUT TO MOVE
INTO PRODUCTION. TO A GREAT
EXTENT BECAUSE OF CALIFORNIA'S
INVESTMENTS AND BECAUSE OF THE
PARTNERSHIP SUPPORTS. THREE
OPERATORS AND FLEETS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'RE
SEEING. THE ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES MOVE FORWARD AT A
PHENOMENAL PACE. WELL WE DO
ALSO NEED TO TAKE A STEP BACK
THAT'S WHAT'S POSSIBLE AND
WHAT'S MOVING FORWARD BUT WE
REALLY DO NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT
CAN WE DO NOW. AND THEN WHAT
CAN WE DO AS WE MOVE TO WHERE
WE NEED TO BE IN TWENTY THIRTY
TO TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. WE DO
KNOW THAT ALL THE TECHNOLOGIES
THAT SERVICE OUR PORTS AND OUR
REGIONS NEED TO BOTH ADDRESS
CRITERION PENSIONS OR THINGS
THAT CAUSE SMOG. AND CLIMATE
EMISSIONS AND THEY NEED TO DO
IT AT THE SAME TIME THIS IS THE
MOST DIFFICULT THING THAT WE
HAVE FACED IN A LONG TIME. NOW
IN TERMS OF TECHNOLOGY
READINESS WE KNOW THAT LOW
EMISSION TECHNOLOGIES SOME
PEOPLE CALL THOSE- NEAR ZERO
SUCH AS NATURAL GAS LOW KNOCKS
TRUCKS OR PROPANE. THEY ARE
READY NOW AS WE'VE DONE THESE
TECHNOLOGY ANALYSES OF
READINESS FOR THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD ANOTHER PARTNERS AS YOU
CAN SEE KIND OF WHERE THEIR
CIRCLES ARE IN THE CRAFT. THERE
AT THE COMMERCIAL STAGE AND
THEY ARE DEFINITELY READY TO
FOR ACTION. BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
BE VERY AWARE OF WHAT'S COMING
DOWN THE PIKE NEXT. AND WHEN IT
COMES TO ZERO EMISSIONS
TECHNOLOGIES THEY WERE CLOSE
BEHIND. THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE
MOVING FROM PILOT STAGE INTO
THE EARLY COMMERCIAL STAGE OF
MANUFACTURING INCLUDING IN
DRAINAGE. AND REGIONAL HEAVY
HAUL APPLICATIONS SO A LOT OF
PEOPLE DO ASK CAN WE SHOULD THE
SALES GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN LAID
OUT BY THE STATE IN A C. T. IN
THE GOVERNOR'S SCHOOLS FOR
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE AT THE PORT
SCHOOLS. IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
FOR ZERO EMISSIONS. AND THE
SHORT ANSWER IS YES ABSOLUTELY
WE CAN'T THE TECHNOLOGY IS ON
THE PATH TO DO THAT. AND AS WE
LOOK AT THAT PHASING FOR THAT
TRANSITION WE CAN SEE. THE
RAPID DEVELOPMENT OF THE
TECHNOLOGY INTO THEY HAVE A
STEP WITH PATIENTS AND INDEED.
WE WILL BE SAYING A LONGER AND
LONG HAUL TRUCKS. ZERO
EMISSIONS- AT LEAST THE FIRST
APPLICATIONS OF THOSE BY THE.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR TIME
FOR IT. AND AS WE WHAT. KIND OF
MEASURE THE NUMBERS OF MODELS
COMING INTO MARKET PLACE BOTH
TODAY AND IN THE- WE- THE
NUMBER OF MODELS BEING-
AVAILABLE. IN MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS DOUBLING BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE SO IT IS AN
EXCITING TIME THE TECHNOLOGY IS
MOVING. WE'RE MOVING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION. HAVING SAID
THAT AND I HEARD WHAT WAS
EARLIER SAID BUT CHERYL DONALD
I REALLY RESPECT THAT.
INFRASTRUCTURE IS ONE OF OUR
BIG LIPS WE ARE SEEING THE
TECHNOLOGY MOVES FORWARD THE
VEHICLES WILL BE THERE THE
BUSINESS CASE IS ACTUALLY
STARTED TO SHOW ITSELF.IN THE
TOTAL COST OF OWNERSHIP THESE
ARE GOING TO BE CHEAPER TO
OPERATE VEHICLES. HOWEVER WE DO
NEED TO GET AHEAD OF THE CURVE
WHEN IT COMES TO INSTALLING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE FUELING.
TO SUPPORT THE- AS WE LOOK AT
THIS WE'RE GOING TO SEE DEPOT
CHARGING BEING THE FIRST
PRIMARY- CHARGING THAT WE WILL
NEED HOWEVER. WE WILL NEED TO
HAVE REGIONAL FAST CHARGE HOPES
TO MAKE SURE THAT TRADE TRUCKS
NO MATTER WHERE THEY ARE AT
THEIR CYCLE WILL ALWAYS BE
CLOSE TO A PLACE TO TOP UP
WHETHER THAT'S- HYDROGEN
WHETHER THAT'S ELECTRICITY OR-
FIVE NATURAL GAS. WE ALSO WILL
NAY CORD OR BASED ON A FUNDING
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY GET
THESE LONG HAUL TRUCKS OUT ON
THE ROAD AS THEY BECOME
AVAILABLE. REALLY IN JUST THE
NEXT FEW YEARS. SO THAT WE CAN
BE LEANING TOWARDS OUR OUTCOME
OF TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. SO WHEN
IT COMES TO WHAT WE WOULD SEE
IS NEEDED TO MAKE SURE THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO MEET.
ITS THE GOALS OF KEEPING ITS
PORTS ACTIVE ITS GOODS MOVEMENT
TO COMPETITIVE AROUND THE
WORLD. WE WILL LOOK AT ALL
HANDS ON DECK APPROACH HE
STATE NEEDS TO BE A STRONG AND
AGGRESSIVE PARTNER. NOT JUST ON
THE REGULATORY SIDE WHICH IS
NECESSARY TO SEND SIGNALS. BUT
THEN ON THE INCENTIVE SIDE. ON
THE INVESTMENT SIDE FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE. ON REALLY
SETTING IN PLACE PILOT PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE GREATLY HELPED
FLEETS. UTILITIES AND PORTS
WORK AND HOW TO GET TO SCALE
FASTER. BUT WE NEED TO BE MORE
INNOVATIVE AND ADDITIONAL
REGULATIONS THAT CAN BRING
INDUCEMENTS AND BENEFITS INTO
THE MARKET PLACE- AND THEN WE
NEED ALL OF THESE OTHER PLAYERS
CITIES UTILITIES AND FLEETS.
ARE TO TAKE THEIR PART TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THIS ACTIVE RAMP
UP. SO WITH THAT I WILL. I WILL
STOP WELL MY PRESENTATION- BUT
I THINK WE ARE AT AN EXCITING
TIME. AND THE STATE IS POISED
TO LEAD THE WORLD OTHERS ARE
DOING THE SAME THING BUT
CALIFORNIA'S STILL IS ON THE
LEADING EDGE LET'S CHANGE. AND
I WILL SAY AND THERE IS DEBATE
ON THIS POINT BUT I TRULY
BELIEVE THIS WILL MAKE OUR
PORTS MORE COMPETITIVE. BECAUSE
WHAT WE'RE DOING NOW IS WHAT
THE REST OF THE WORLD WILL BE
TO DO. AND WE'LL GET THEIR
FIRST AND HAVE THE EXPERTISE TO
LEAD. SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
CHAIR OF DONALD AND- THAT IS MY
TESTIMONY. THANK YOU MISTER
ENAMORED BY RESPONDING TO MANY
OF THESE REGULATIONS WITH
INNOVATIONS SO THANK YOU WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO MIKE JACOB.
HIS VICE PRESIDENT GENERAL
COUNSEL THE PACIFIC. MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION MR JACOB.
GOOD MORNING- MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MIKE JACOB WHAT THE
NSA- GOOD MORNING CENTER
GONZALEZ. REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
HAVING US AND- JUST WANT TO
START BY ECHOING ALL THE OTHER
COMMENTS THIS MORNING WE
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP THE
CRITICAL SUPPORT FOR INDUSTRY
IS THE FIRST CHANCE. WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO- PUBLICLY SAY THANK
YOU. FOR ALL THE SUPPORT OF THE
LAST YEAR WE REALLY APPRECIATED
THAT'S A- REALLY IMPORTANT I'M
SO BLESSED THAT REPRESENTATIVES
ACTUALLY. THERE AND I WALKED
THE WALK AND NOT JUST TALK THE
TALK SO WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT I DO HAVE A SHORT
PRESENTATION- AND THEN I'M
GONNA SHARE THAT WITH YOU RIGHT
NOW- THE- TOPIC. OBVIOUSLY
NEEDS A CONTEXT IN THE CONTEXT
FOR US- IS THAT- WE HAVE BEEN
MAKING A LOT OF PROGRESS ON ON-
THE ENVIRONMENT AFFRONT. AND WE
HAVE BUT TO BUILD ON THOSE ARE
QUALITY SUCCESSES WE HAVE TO DO
IT PRACTICALLY WE HAVE TO DO
IT. NOT KNOWING WHERE WE CAME
FROM. I'M SO THE FIRST REAL BIG
FOR A UP FROM THE STATE FROM A
REGULATORY PERSPECTIVE AND
PERMANENT CENTER PERSPECTIVE
CAME IN TWO THOUSAND SIX. WITH
THE ADOPTION BECAUSE MOVEMENT
EMISSION REDUCTION PLAN. NOT
ONLY THAT- THAT COINCIDE WITH
PASSAGE OF PROP ONE B. WHICH
INCLUDED FOR THE FIRST TIME.
BILL STATE COMMIT TO GROW- AND
UNDER. OF VERSION OF THE- THAT
NEEDED TO HAPPEN WITH RESPECT
AIR QUALITY BUT THE GOVERNMENT
MEASUREMENT PRODUCTION PROGRAM
ADDITIONALLY IT RESULTED IN A
SERIES IN A SUITE OF
REGULATIONS THAT COST. FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT
OVERTIME- AND THOSE IMMEDIATELY
BEGAN TO HAVE RESULTS GOT A
COUPLE OF YEARS OF. NUMBER FOR
FOLKS TAKE A LOOK AT TWENTY
FOURTEEN- YOU SEE WE HAVE VERY
DRAMATIC REDUCTIONS- REPORTER
ARB ACROSS THE BOARD IN TERMS
OF- ESPECIALLY WITH RESPECT TO
CREATE A POLLUTANTS- HAND DYED
DIESEL PM- SIXTEEN THE PORT OF
LA AND LONG BEACH EMISSIONS
INVENTORY- THOSE EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS GROWING VERY
DRAMATIC YOU CAN SEE THOSE
THOSE ACROSS ALL SECTORS- AND-
WHAT IT DOES WITH THAT THE
LIMIT THAT YOU ALL NOW WHICH
IS- ONCE YOU'VE DONE. THE REAL
HEAVY LEFT. WHAT COMES NEXT IS
EXCEPTIONAL EXCEPTIONALLY HARD
BUT ALSO EXCEPTIONALLY
EXPENSIVE- SO AFTER WE REDUCE
THE FIRST 96% OF OUR DAYS WHAT
MATTER FROM HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS.
AND EQUIPMENT FROM TWO THOUSAND
NOT SIX THROUGH TWENTY SIXTEEN.
LAST 4% IS. WHERE THINGS GET
REALLY HARD AND EXPENSIVE- OF
OAKLAND'S- I TWENTY SEVENTEEN
INVENTORY. I KNOW THAT- OF NOTE
THE- TRUCKING EMISSIONS FOR
PEACE OF THE MATTER DOWN TO
ZERO POINT THREE MONTHS PER
YEAR AT SIX HUNDRED POUNDS
ISRAEL MISSIONS FROM THE ENTIRE
TRUCKING FLEET PORT OF OAKLAND-
AND AT THE PORT OF LA IS THE
TWENTY NINETEEN AIR QUALITY
REPORT CARD. OUT THAT THE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE CLEANER
ACTUAL PLAN GOALS- MARKETING
EXCEEDED- IN TWENTY NINETEEN SO
WE'RE WE'RE FOUR YEARS AHEAD OF
SCHEDULE I'M SURE- DIRECTOR
GENERAL WILL TALK A LITTLE BIT
MORE. WITH SOME SPECIFICITY BUT
WE ARE DOING HUMANS WORK WE ARE
REALLY DOING A GREAT JOB AT
REDUCING EMISSIONS IN THAT
CONTEXT I THINK IT'S REFLECTIVE
OF NOT JUST WAS INVESTMENTS IN
THOSE REGULATIONS BUT ALSO. I
THINK REFLECTIVE OF. IT'S WHICH
IS- WE DO HAVE CONCENTRATED-
IMPACT ON OUR COMMUNITY AND
THOSE ARE WE NEED TO CONTROL
FOR- BUT IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
GREATER SOUTH COAST AIR BASIN
FOR EXAMPLE- WE ARE NOT. MAJOR
CONTRIBUTORS ARE WRIT LARGE-
AND AS OF TWENTY FIFTEEN. WE'RE
VERY PLEASED TO SHOW THAT WE'RE
VERY ACTUALLY- SMALL. NET
CONTRIBUTORS AND WHEN IT LOOKS
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE ESTATE AS
A WHOLE WITH RESPECT TO OUR-
GHG EMISSIONS. WE'RE ABOUT ZERO
POINT ZERO SEVEN FOUR SEVEN. OF
ALL STATE EMISSIONS AND I THINK
THAT IS REALLY REFLECTIVE OF
THE JOB THAT WE'VE DONE BUT
ALSO THE SCOPE AND SCALE- OF
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ONE OF
THE OTHER THINGS WE'VE DONE
REALLY WELL I KNOW I'M RUNNING
OUT OF TIME BUT OF TOUCH TO A
CASE STUDIES REALLY QUICK. AND
VESSELS BURKE. HERE'S WHAT ONE
OF THE HAPPEN- THE REGULATIONS
WHAT HAPPENED AFTER YOU SAW THE
TWO THOUSAND SIX. WE PUT IN A
REGULATION WE ARE PROJECTED TO
HAVE A AMAZING REDUCTION IF YOU
FOLLOW THE RULE. ALL THE WAY
THROUGH TO- TWENTY TWENTY OF
ZERO POINT ONE SEVEN. FUNDS PER
DAY DIESEL PM PRODUCTION FOR
ONE POINT FOUR THREE. WHAT WE
FOUND IS THAT THE CARD IS
ACTUALLY PROJECTING BY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BY THIS YEAR WE
ACTUALLY HAVE ZERO POINT ZERO
SIX. SO WE ARE OUTPERFORMING
OUR REGULATORY. POLLS THREE
TWENTY THIRTY ONE THE- PROP
PROJECTION BY A R. B. IS THAT
WE'D BE AT ZERO POINT ONE ZERO.
TRANSPORTATION DIESEL PM EVEN
WITH ADDITIONAL GROWTH IN OUR
SYSTEM OF ANOTHER DECK- THAT IS
THAT IS PHENOMENAL CONTROL- AND
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE EVEN
WITHOUT THE ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE BEING
DISCUSSED. WITH RESPECT TO
SHORE POWER RIGHT NOW- WHEN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THESE THE
CONTEXT AGAIN- IT'S IN THE
CONTEXT OF WHAT PEOPLE EXPECTED
TO HAVE IN TERMS OF GROWTH-
SEVEN THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE EXPECT THE
CITY- HERE IT IS. MORE SPECIFIC
FOR SAN PEDRO BAY PORTS THOSE
RED TRIANGLES THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S OUR ACTUAL GROWTH. I'M
SO WE'RE PLANNING FOR THESE
THESE RULES WERE ALSO PLANNING
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE- WE HAVE.
CONSISTENTLY UNDERPERFORM THOSE
AND IS YOUR SEATS- WITH RESPECT
OUR OUR ACTUAL GROWTH THOSE
GREEN LINES THAT REPRESENTS THE
U. S. WEST COAST. PREPARE
OAKLAND THE PACIFIC NORTHWEST-
AND WE ARE LOSING SOME MARKET
SHARE SO WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE
US- IT LEADS US AND FOCUSING
ON. HOW DO WE MAXIMIZE
INVESTMENT IN IT BUT WAS COST
HIGHEST RETURN. BECAUSE WE'RE
NOT GENERATING THE PROFITS THAT
WE EXPECTED TO- AND ONE OF THE
WAYS TO DO THAT IS TO BE
FLEXIBLE ABOUT ACHIEVING GOALS-
RESULTS OF A STUDY THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING RIGHT NOW IS THAT.
YOU CAN ACTUALLY ACHIEVE BETTER
RESULTS IN TERMS OF CUMULATIVE
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS- BOSS
WITCHING TO HYBRID TECHNOLOGY
WHICH WOULD INCLUDE DIESEL
GENSETS WITH BATTERIES AS
OPPOSED TO WAITING LONGER. FOR
JUST ZERO EMISSIONS SO JUST
FIVE YEARS EARLIER INTRODUCTION
OF HYBRID- RUBBER TIRED GANTRY
IN THIS EXAMPLE OR POP INTO OUR
EMISSIONS BECAME A BNEFITS OF
THOSE EMISSION REDUCTIONS IF
YOU DO THOSE INVESTMENTS
EARLIER. ACTUALLY MEAN THAT
YOUR GONNA HAVE GREATER
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS BOTH IN
GHGS AND IN AND OUT LOCAL. AND
REGIONAL CRITERIA POLLUTANTS-
TWENTY FOUR AT THE- BUT THEY'RE
GOOD IN. AND FINALLY- JUST TO
POINT OUT THAT THAT ALL THESE
THINGS HAPPEN NOT JUST IN A
STATEWIDE CONTESTS BUT IN A
GLOBAL CONTEXT. IF YOU ARE
DIVERTING CARGO. YOU ARE
INCREASING GHGS THAT'S THE LAST
THING YOU WANT TO DO IS HAVE
CARGO BY. FOR A REPEAT AND GULF
COAST PORTS. OUR STUDY IS THAT
IT WOULD- INCREASE EMISSIONS BY%
20% ON AVERAGE AND SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIX. THAT'S FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND METRIC TONNES
OF GHG EMISSIONS- THAT GOES
BACKWARDS THAT IS NOT IN THE
STATE'S GOALS. HANDED CERTAINLY
DOES NOT CORRELATE WITH WHAT WE
WANT TO HAVE HAPPEN ON THE ON
THE BUSINESS SIDE EITHER SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE- THE HEARING
AND- OUR OUR FOR A POLICY OF
THIS PAST YEAR WILL BE TALKING
ABOUT REALLY IS ABOUT HOW DO WE
ALIGN PUBLIC FUNDING
INVESTMENTS TO SUPPORT LONG.
TERM REMISSIONS IN NEAR ZERO.
TRANSITIONS AND HOW DO WE
PRIORITIZE FLEXIBLE COMPLIANCE
OPTIONS AND SENATE FUNDING
WHICH YOU. AND THAT WOULD GO
FORWARD TO YOU- WORKING WITH
THINGS HAPPEN AND THAT THANK
YOU FOR INCLUDING US AND BE. HE
DROPPED OFF THERE AT THE END
THEIR ARMS JACOB THANK YOU FOR
THAT PRESENTATION WHEN I REALLY
WANT TO CHRISTIAN MODEL IT
LIVES HERE IN THE ROOM. LIVE IN
PERSON. AND HE IS FRAWLEY'S
VICE PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS THE CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION. I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISSILE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE INVITATION HERE
TODAY IT'S MY FIRST TIME IN THE
BUILDING IN ABOUT A YEAR IT'S
GREAT TO BE HERE AND HOW TO SAY.
SO AGAIN MY NAME IS KRISHNA
VICE PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT
AFFAIRS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION. SO
PREPARING FOR TODAY'S PANEL- WE
ARE ASKED TO CONSIDER SOME
QUESTIONS. WHAT IS THE ROLE OF
TRUCKING IN CONTRIBUTING TO
GREEN PARKS AND GREEN A GREEN
GOODS MOVEMENT. AND MEETING THE
STATE'S ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS
WHAT ARE THE HURDLES AND WHAT
SUPPORT IS NEEDED FROM THE
STATE. TO THE FIRST QUESTION
ABOUT TRUCKING IS ROLE IN
CONTRIBUTING TO GROUP IMPORTS
IN OUR STATEWIDE GOALS. I'M
HAPPY TO SAY THE TRUCKING HAS
STEPPED UP HAS LED AND WILL
CONTINUE TO LEAD WHEN IT COMES
TO CLEANING THE YEAR. INCLUDED
IN THE COMMITTEE PACKETS ARE
THE LATEST EMISSION REDUCTION
NUMBERS FROM THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES FOR TWENTY NINETEEN AND
I THINK MISTER JACOB COVERED
SOME OF THIS ALREADY BUT-
THROUGH ABOUT. ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN INDUSTRY INVESTMENT
DIESEL PARTICULATE EMISSIONS
FROM PORT TRUCKING. WHICH IS
THE POLLUTANT OF CONCERN FOR
LOCALIZED HEALTH IMPACT HAVE
BEEN REDUCED BY NINETY SEVEN
PERCENT. NITROGEN OXIDES WHICH
CONTRIBUTE TO REGIONAL OZONE
LEVELS AND SMOG. HAVE FALLEN BY
SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT. THESE
EMISSIONS WILL AGAIN FALL IN
TWENTY TWENTY THREE ONCE THE
STATE AIR BOARD STATEWIDE RULES
ARE FULLY PHASED IN. SO WHILE
EMISSIONS ARE DOWN ACROSS OLD
PORT RELATED EQUIPMENT AND I
GOT TO GIVE COMPLIMENTS TO ALL
OF OUR PORT PARTNERS OF FOR
THAT. QUITE LITERALLY NO
SEGMENT OF THE INDUSTRY HAS
DONE MORE TO REDUCE THESE
POLLUTANTS AND TRUCKING. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD YOU CAN EXPECT
TRUCKS TO GET EVEN CLEANER IS-
CARBON BOTH FEDERAL EPA- LOOK
TO ADOPT A NEW LOWER KNOCKS
STANDARDS TO GET TO THAT VERY
FINAL INCREMENTS. OF THOSE
KNOCKS- SMOG FORMING EMISSIONS.
A CARD DATA ALSO SUGGESTS THAT
GROSS EMITTERS MAKING UP JUST
3% OF TRUCKS ON THE ROAD
CONTRIBUTES 65% OF ALL.
PARTICULATE EMISSIONS AND SO I
WANT TO REPEAT THAT DOESN'T
HAVE A STAKE. 3% OF ALL TRUCKS
ON THE ROAD- DUE IN ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF ALL THE EMISSIONS. SO
IF YOU SEE A SMOKING TRUCK. IS
LIKELY EITHER NOT COMPLIANT
WITH STATE REGULATIONS IS
SEVERELY MALFUNCTIONING OR HAS
BEEN INTENTIONALLY TAMPERED
WITH SO. IF YOU GET THOSE
CONSIDERING COMPLAINTS ABOUT
SMOKING TRUCKS THAT THOSE ARE
NOT PROPERLY FUNCTIONING.
TRUCKS WITH FUNCTIONING
EMISSION CONTROL SYSTEMS TO
QUOTE THE A RESOURCES BOARD.
VIRTUALLY ELIMINATE DIESEL
PARTICULATES. DELETE BETWEEN A
GROSS EMITTING A TRUCK IN A
CLEAN ONE IS ACTUALLY
SIGNIFICANT LARK SIGNIFICANTLY
LARGER. THAN MOVING FROM A
CLEAN DIESEL TO ELECTRIC. D. D.
CLEANER DIESELS ARE SO MUCH.
BETTER THAN ONE WHICH IS
AGGRESSIVE MALFUNCTIONING THAT
THAT IS THE BIGGEST BANG FOR
THE BUCK RATHER THAN MOVING TO
ELECTRIC. AND SO WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE RESOURCES BOARD ON
PROGRAMS TO IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS THESE GROSS EMITTERS
WITHOUT OVER BURDENING. THE
VA'S MAJORITY OF TRUCK OWNERS
WHO ARE PERSON COMPLY IN GOING
ABOUT THEIR- THEIR BUSINESS IN
THE RIGHT WAY. BUT AS WE KNOW
AND HAVE DISCUSSED TODAY THE
GOAL OF THE STATE IS TO
TRANSITION A SPECIFICALLY PORT
DRAYAGE TRUCKS ZERO EMISSION BY
THE YEAR TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
AND AS WE LOOK TOWARDS THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS THERE'S A MAJOR HURDLES
THAT ALL BREAK INTO FOUR
CATEGORIES. COST WEIGHT RANGE
AND INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR COST
ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS COST
APPROXIMATELY TWO TO THREE
TIMES MORE THAN THEIR DIESEL
COUNTERPARTS A BRAND NEW DIESEL
TRUCK COSTS. ANYWHERE FROM A
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. ZERO
EMISSION TRUCKS ARE GOING TO BE
QUITE A BIT MORE EXPENSIVE. AND
I DO WANNA AGREE WITH MR VAN
AMBURG THERE ARE POSSIBLE- COST
SAVINGS FROM OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE THERE FOR FEWER
MOVING PARTS. GENERALLY
SPEAKING ELECTRICITY IS MORE
CHEAP. BUT WE STILL REALLY
DON'T HAVE REAL WORLD
EXPERIENCE WITH THOSE SAVINGS-
THEY CAN WEIGH AS MUCH AS SIX
TO EIGHT THOUSAND POUNDS MORE
THAN A DIESEL TRUCK THAT IS A
SIGNIFICANT ISSUE WHEN IT COMES
TO. YOU'RE PROBABLY GONNA HAVE
TO HAVE MORE TRUCKS TO MOVE THE
SAME AMOUNT OF CARGO- THE RANGE
IS LIMITED TO ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILES PER CHARGE
DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF THE
BATTERY PACK. NOT EXACTLY
SUITABLE FOR LONGER RANGE
FALLS. AND FINALLY THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CHARGING FUEL
THESE TRUCKS IN THE CASE OF
HYDROGEN. IS NEARLY NONEXISTENT
WERE REALLY STARTING FROM THE
GROUND LEVEL OP. AND I CAN TELL
YOU THAT- ISSUES PERTAINING TO
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE GOING TO BE.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. VERY SITE
SPECIFIC THERE'S NO
GENERALIZATION ABOUT HOW EASY
IT IS TO INSTALL
INFRASTRUCTURE. JUST HEARD FOR
THE FIRST TIME THAT YOU KNOW IF
A NEW SUBSTATION UPGRADE IS
REQUIRED FOR ONE OF THE SITES.
THAT COULD BE AS MUCH AS A FIVE
TO SEVEN YEAR PROCESS FIRST
TIMER HEARD HAD ABOUT A MONTH
AGO SO. A VERY COMPLICATED. AB
GIVEN THESE CHALLENGES THE BEST
USE CASE AND I THINK I'M
AGREEING. WITH MR VAN AMBURG ON
THIS- FOR TODAY'S REMISSION
TRUCKS. ARE REALLY LOCAL HALL
SMALLER CLASS TRUCKS. WERE
WEIGHT IS NOT AN ISSUE. ARE YOU
OPERATE ON A RELATIVELY FIXED
ROUTE WITHIN LIMITED RANGES YOU
CAN USE A SMALLER AND SHE PER
BATTERY. AND YOU CAN SENSE YOUR
DEPOT CHARGE OVERNIGHT IN ONE
LOCATION- TO AVOID A TIME USE
AND DEMAND CHARGES YOU REALLY
WANT TO CENTRALLY CHARGE VERY
SLOWLY. AT A TIME WHERE YOU'RE
NOT GONNA BE PENALIZED FOR
DOING SO. YOU KNOW QUITE
FRANKLY PORT DRAYAGE IS NOT
NECESSARILY THIS BEST USE CASE.
IN THE EARLY YEARS OF THIS
WE'RE LIKELY LOOKING AT A
SMALLER SUBSET OF DRAYAGE WORK
WHICH IS GOING TO BE SUITABLE.
FOR THE TECHNOLOGIES WE KNOW IT
TODAY. AND EVEN THEN INDUSTRY
IS GOING TO NEED SIGNIFICANT
SUPPORT FROM THE STATE.
RESOURCES BOARD ESTIMATES IT
NEEDS ABOUT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR TO ACCOMPLISH
ITS TRUCK ELECTRIFICATION
GOALS. THE GOVERNOR'S CURRENT
BUDGET PROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THIS YEAR SO THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT GAP- THIS
UNDERSCORES THE NEED TO RE
AUTHORIZE EXISTING INCENTIVE
FUNDS AND LOOK FOR NEW
OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP TRUCKERS.
FOR ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS. BEATS
SALES TAX CREDITS FINANCING
MECHANISMS I THINK THAT THE
TERM WAS USE ALL HADS ON DECK.
THE STATE MUST EMPLOY EVERY%
TOOL AT ITS DISPOSAL IF IT IS
SERIOUS ABOUT ACCOMPLISHING
THESE GOALS. AND THE TIMELINE
SET OUT. IN EVEN WITHOUT
SUPPORT I WOULD BE REMISS NOT
TO. TEMPER SOME EXPECTATIONS I
THINK YOU'VE- HEARD THE
OPTIMISTIC SIDE I JUST WANT TO
YOU KNOW BRING A LITTLE BIT- OF
THE REALISTIC SIDE TO THIS
THAT. THIS IS GOING TO BE A
VERY- EXPENSIVE EXTREMELY
COMPLICATED TRANSITION. AND WE
ARE STARTING NEARLY FROM
SCRATCH THE HEAVY DUTY.
ELECTRIC TRUCKING MARKET IS
REALLY LAGGING LIGHT DUTY BUT I
WOULD SAY YOU KNOW TWO OR THREE
DECADES. AND SO THEREFORE. YOU
KNOW I WOULD JUST URGE. POLICY
MAKERS TO NOT DEFINE SUCCESS OR
FAILURE BY THE ABILITY TO MEET
ARBITRARY GOALS AND TIMELINES.
BUT WE REALLY NEED TO
COLLECTIVELY ROLL UP OUR
SLEEVES. FOCUS ON THE HARD WORK
AHEAD TO GET REAL TRUCKERS IN
REAL ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS.
MAKING A REAL LIVING. AND SO WE
LOOK FORWARD TO OUR CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. PARTICIPATE
HERE TO. GREAT I THANK YOU MR
SCHIMMEL FOR ALWAYS BEING A
VOICE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKING ASSOCIATION GREEN. THE
CHOCOLATES ROUTINES TO THE
TABLE SO ALL OFTEN WITH THAT
WE'RE GONNA TOMORROW. WAS
EXPECTED DIRECTOR THE PORT. OF
LONG BEACH I KNOW WE HAVE OUR
PEOPLE ON THE LINE AFTER THIS
WE HAVE A COUPLE MORE SPEAKERS-
WE HAVE A HARD STOP AT A JUST
SHORT OF NOON. SO LET'S PROCEED
WITH MR MARIO CORDERO OF LONG
BEACH PORT OF LONG BEACH. CAN
EVERYBODY HEAR ME. I CAN HEAR
YOU OKAY THANK YOU AND I
BELIEVE I HAVE A POWER POINT
PRESENTATION BUT THANK YOU
GERALD ON THE MEMBERS OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR ALLOWING
THE PORT COMMITTEE ISSUED A
PROPOSED SOLUTIONS TO MAKING
CALIFORNIA AGREED TO CALL. I
PERSONALLY WANT TO THANK A
SINGLE DAUGHTER WHO REPRESENTS
LONG BEACH FOR BEING AN
IMPACTFUL ADVOCATE FOR THE PORT
AND THE CITY LONG BEACH AND
ALSO THANK SENATOR LENA
CONSULTANTS NOT ONLY FOR HER
SUPPORT OF THE PORT INDUSTRY
BUT OBVIOUSLY HER COMMENTS SHE
MADE. THIS MORNING WHICH ARE
VERY A PROPOS. I AM THE
EXECUTOR OF THE PRO LOBBYIST
SECOND LARGE CONTAINER PORT IN
UNITED STATES TOGETHER WITH THE
PRO LOS ANGELES OUR TOPICS
ACCOUNTS FOR FORTY PERCENT. OF
GOODS MOVED IN THE COUNTRY.
PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC OR POOR
SPAWNING DECLINED BY 8% WHAT
OTHER PORTS SUCH AS HOUSTON.
SALAS TEN POINT THREE
INCREASING THEIR CARGO AND
STATE. IN GEORGIA A 7% INCREASE.
OTHER WORDS ARE BECOMING MORE.
BECAUSE THEY'RE STATES HAVE
THANK YOU HALF AND CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN THE SUCCESS OF THE
REPORTS. PUTTING CALIFORNIA AND
A COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE
NATIONAL. WHAT HAS MADE
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT TO THE
REDUCTION OF EMISSIONS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO GET OVER
LOS ANGELES THAT IS PORTABLE
AIR CLEAN TRUCK PLANT. WAS THE
FIRST OF ITS KIND INSPIRE
SIMILAR PROGRAMS WERE OPEN AND
NEW YORK NEW JERSEY. LAUNCHED
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
PROGRAM HAS IMPROVED SAFETY
SECURITY AND AIR QUALITY BY
BETTING TRUCK THAT DID NOT MEET
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN COVER
EMISSIONS STANDARDS. OKAY THERE
ARE MORE THAN EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
TRUCKS REGISTERED IMPORTER
LOBBIES PORTABILITY CLEAN TRUCK
PROGRAM WITH NEARLY 60% MEETING
AT LEAST TWENTY TEN STANDARDS
AND THE GROWING NUMBER NEARLY
NOW A QUARTER DEPLETE OUR MODEL
YEAR TWENTY FOURTEEN OR NEW
YORK. THE CLEAN TRUCK PROGRAM
HAS REDUCED AIR POLLUTION FROM
HARPER TRUCKS. BY ABOUT 90% THE
PROGRAM WHICH HAS INVESTED MORE
IN ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO EVERY CONTAINER. IS
EQUIPPED WITH ARE PAR FOUR
SHIPS PLUGIN AT BIRTH TO POWER
PUMPS LIGHTING COMMUNICATIONS
AND OTHER SYSTEMS. RATHER THAN
RUNNING ON DIESEL ENGINES. THIS
IS LED TO A 95% REDUCTION IN
RELATED EMISSIONS NEXT ONE. THE
CLEAN AIR ACTION PLAN UPDATE IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT'S AN
AMBITIOUS BUT A VIABLE PLAN
INCLUDES THOSE OF JURY MISSION
KARBO HAVING IT PUT IN BY
TWENTY THIRTY AND- YOUR MISSION
TRUCKS BY TWENTY THIRTY FIVE.
BEING THE FIRST IN SOMETHING
THAT IS BIG AND WHAT EMAIL IS
ALWAYS DIFFICULT. WE OPTED FOR
THE CAB TWO THOUSAND SIX WE
WERE TOLD IT WOULD BE THE END
OF OUR BUSINESS. INSTEAD WE'RE
THRIVING. BEING ENVIRONMENTALLY
RESPONSIBLE ONE REMAINING
COMPETITIVE AND EVEN CHANGING
MARKET COMES WITH MANY
CHALLENGES. BUT WE ALSO KNOW
THAT GROWING OUR BUSINESS AND
GROWING GRADE ARE NOT MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE.
RICHARD SHIRO
STRAIGHT STROKES BUT THE
CURRENT ESTIMATE OF THOSE
TRUCKS RANGE ANYWHERE FROM
THREE HUNDRED TO THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND FOR TRUCKS. AT A
OF YOUR COLLECTIONS HE BIGGEST.
ROAST AND LOCAL TAXES AND
INSURANCE. HOW IS IT THAT IT'S
POSSIBLE FOR INDEPENDENT
TRUCKERS OR EVEN. COMPANIES TO
MAKE SUCH AN EX YEAH IN FACT
THE CRIPPLING COMMERCE THE
BETTER. ALL AND ALL IT'S FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLAR. IN QUESTION IS
THAT REALLY IT MARKET READY. WE
NEED TO BUILD A SO BIRDS. TO
GET A SECURITY. BUT THAT WE
WOULD THAT WILL TAKE TIME AS
YOU HEARD DEALERS. THE NEW TERM
SOLUTION TO GET CLEANER NOW IS
TO GET MORE NEAR ZERO MISS
TRUCKS THE ROAD. WHAT WHAT ZERO
TECHNOLOGY TO MARKET. NEAR ZERO
TRUCKS EXIST. AND COME A SMALL
WHICH AHEAD DEPRIVED UPON
HUNTER. THOUSAND OR ENOUGH GAS.
THIS IS MORE OF. NEAR ZERO TO.
WE CAN CLEAN THE AIR NOW.
VERSUS WAITING TEN TO FIFTEEN
YEARS FROM.I SUPPORT MOVES
TOWARDS NEAR ZERO ENSURING
MISSION OPERATIONS IT'S REAL.
ON. WE NEED AN ENERGY AND SHE
PLAN EXCELLENT. YES THE MINUTE
COSTS TO CHEAT REPORTS CLEANER
ACTION PLAN JURY MISSION GOAL
IS ESTIMATED TO BE ANYWHERE
FROM TWELVE TO FOURTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS BY TWENTY TWENTY.
THANKS FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE I'LL SAY
THAT AGAIN WELL THE FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING A ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION JURY MISSION TECHNOLOGY
AND INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
ITS ZERO EMISSION EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND CARP ESTIMATES WILL
PROVIDE A HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
MILLION. EIGHT HUNDRED PROJECT
BUT THE COST TO ACHIEVE THAT IS
MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
BILLION NATIONAL. THE SECOND
HELP. WE CAN HOW YOU CAN HELP.
ME FURTHER US INDICATE THAT
PROPOSAL SUCH AS ASSEMBLY
O'DONNELL'S AB THREE SIXTY FIVE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE SALE TAX
EXEMPTION FOR NEAR ZERO
ANSWERED MISSION HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS. WILL GREATLY OF. IS THE
FIRST STEP FOR SURE THE
PARLIAMENT IS PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THIS BILL. OTHER TUNES
INCLUDE EXPEDITED PERMITTING
BERMAN STREAMLINED PROCESS
WITHOUT. WITHOUT COMPRISED HI
FROM RISING BY MIDDLE
PROTECTIONS TAX CREDITS FOR
HEAVY DUTY ZERO EMISSION.
VEHICLES AND CREATING
AFFORDABLE INSURANCE POLICY
OPTIONS FOR THOSE NEW BRICK
INCLUDES. INCENTIVES ARE MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN REGULATIONS WHAT
DID YOU REGULATION WE ARE
MAKING CALIFORNIA LESS
COMPETITIVE TO OTHER US SPORTS.
THE NATIONAL ARBITRATION ZERO
EMISSION REQUIREMENTS WHAT
HELPED TO STRENGTHEN THE
BROADER MARKET FOR THESE
VEHICLES AND KEEP THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS CALIFORNIA
COMPONENT. WE ALSO NEED STATE
LEADERS TO ADVOCATE ZERO
MISSION AND INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
ARE COMPELLED TO STAY SEPARATED
STRONG COALITIONS WITH
CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS WITH
SUCCESSFULLY SECURED
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AT BONDING THAT HAVE MADE THEIR
PORTS MORE COMPETITIVE. WITH
THE SEPARATE A BIG COMPLEX
ACCOUNTING 440% OF THE CARBON
TO UNITED STATES THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NEEDS TO HAVE A
GREATER ROLE IN PROTECTING AND
EXPANDING ITS MARKET. SURE SO
WE. COULD GET RID STE. THAT'S
LIKE AND THE LAST. FIFTEEN
YEARS THE PORT BEACH OUT TO
WHAT SOME IMPOSSIBLE AS IT WERE
MODEL POOREST REDUCE RISKS AND
AIR QUALITY IN TO IS TO MAKE.
ONCE BUT WE CANNOT DO THIS
ALONE AS YOU HEARD TODAY WHEN
YOU THE STATE'S ASSISTANCE ON
MANY FRONTS TO HELP US ACHIEVE
THESE AMBITIOUS AND GROW OUR
ECONOMY. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU TODAY AND POOR LOBBY
STANDS READY TO HELP THE STATE
ACHIEVED ITS ZERO EMISSION
FUTURE THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR
THANK YOU MARIO THANK YOU FOR
ALWAYS BEING A LEADER ON THESE
ISSUES APPRECIATED AND THAT'S
WILL GO TO KRISTEN BECAUSE US
YOU SEE ON PORT DIRECTOR FROM
THE PORT OF HUENEME ME. RESPOND
GOOD MORNING- I MEAN I KNOW THE
LAST PER CENTER HERE AND I'LL
MAKE SURE I GET TO THE OINT
QUICKLY IS KIND OF SET ME UP ON
A BASED ON EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE HEARD HERE THIS MORNING-
I AM GOING TO. SHARE HERE I
THINK A POWER POINT- THE END I
THINK I DID IT. EVERYONE SEE
THAT. YES OKAY GREAT I'M SO
REALLY JUST QUICKER WHEN HE ME-
WE ARE THE FOURTH LARGEST CARGO
PORT IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WERE THE SECOND LARGEST BANANA
IMPORTER IN THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA SERVING AS SUCH A
THIRTEEN STATES IMPORTANT
PRODUCE COMMODITIES REMOVE
AUTOMOTIVE CARGO AND- WE'VE
ALSO SERVED AS A RIB RIVER
VALLEY IN ON THIS PANDEMIC IN
TERMS OF HELPING WITH AG
EXPORTS AS WELL AS- MOVING ON
ENTITIES- BACK INTO THE SYSTEM.
SO JUST A QUICK HIGHLIGHT THERE
ARE WHAT WE DO BUT WANTED TO
REALLY HONE IN ON ON THE BIGGER
PICTURE HERE WAS COURTS DAYS
YESTERDAY AND WE WENT ALONG
WITH THIS THEME OF MEETING THE
MOMENT AND I'M THIS FOCUS GROUP
WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT HOW
WE'RE LEADING THE WORLD AND
THAT IS THE TRUTH REALLY
LEADING THE WORLD IN TERMS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRESS- B. AS
THE- COURT SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE REDUCE PARTICULATE MATTER
80% SOCKS NINETY PERCENT. AND
KNOCKS 50% OUR PORTS ARE DOING
REALLY BIG THINGS WERE REALLY
ON THE CUSP OF INNOVATION WITH
A SHORT SIGHT POWER SYSTEMS-
ALL THE EVR CARGO HANDLING
EQUIPMENT AND WHEN YOU ME WE
ARE GOING TO BE PILOTING ARM IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE L. A.
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL TRUCKS ON
HIM WHEN HE ME WE PUT UP THE
AIR QUALITY OF MONITORS IN A
SCHOOL THAT'S NEAR THE PARDON
WE'RE MATCHING OUR. AND WE'RE
SHARING THAT- WITH THE KEY. THE
WE CAN BE- OPEN AND- ABOUT.
WHAT OUR AIR LOOKS LIKE HERE-
WE GOTTEN FOR NEW AYE. ME THREE
NEW. HYBRID CRANES THAT WE CAN
PLUG IN AND THE STORY OF THE
PORTS IS THAT WE ARE REALLY.
THINKING BIG AND MAKING A LOT
OF PROGRESS IN THE AREA OF THE
AIR QUALITY- AND THAT SAID I
THINK WE REALLY NEED YOUR HELP
TELLING THAT STORY. I'M BECAUSE
I THINK THAT GETS LOST AS MORE
AND MORE AND MORE WITH NO PUN
INTENDED. INTENDED COMES ON
DECK SO THERE'S A SLEW OF
REGULATIONS IN THE PIPELINE. WE
HAVE THE AB MANDATE THERE'S AT
BIRTH REGULATIONS FOR NEW CLASS
FASSEL'S HIGH HEAVY MEDIUM
TRUCKS. HARBOR CRAFT
REGULATIONS CARGO HANDLING-
WHAT MADE REGULATIONS AND THEN
THERE'S THE WHOLE OTHER SECTOR
OF OUR INDUSTRY THAT'S ALSO
GETTING REGULAR- REGULATED. AND
WHEN WE GO TO SAY IN A R. B.
MEETING AND RAISE YOUR CONCERNS
ABOUT ENERGY CAPACITY FOR FILL
ALL THESE MANDATES THEY TELL US
THAT THAT- THE UTILITY
PROVIDERS ARE SET THEY CAN
PROVIDE THE POWER. YEAH WHEN WE
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS- ARM
HE PARTICULARLY WHEN HE MADE.
THE UTILITY PROVIDER SAYS- YOU
NEED TO WE NEED TO DO A SIXTY
MILLION DOLLAR UPGRADE SHE EVEN
JUST DO YOUR NEXT LEVEL. OF
THE- OF THE EEVEE CAPACITY
FORGET ABOUT GETTING TWO ZERO.
AND THEN THAT UTILITY PROVIDER
WANTS US TO DO THAT FEASIBILITY
ANALYSIS IN THAT I THINK
SHOULDN'T BE ON THE BACKS OF
THE POOR TO UNDERSTAND THE
ENERGY NEEDS. OF OUR STATE. TO
BRIAN THREE OUR ARMY THAT THE-
TEST OF ALL THESE- REGULATE IN
THE- CERTAINLY ONE TO HELP THIS.
GETS THEIR BUT THERE REALLY
NEEDS TO BE LEADERSHIP AT THE
STATE LEVEL COMPREHENSIVE.
ANALYSIS OF WHAT IS THE REAL
FEASIBILITY OF GETTING US TO
THE FINISH LINE WITH ALL THESE
REGULATIONS AND WHAT ARE THE
TRUE ENERGY NEEDS- TO SUPPORT.
THESE AMBITIOUS GOALS- AND WE
WOULD LOOK AT THE STEEP THE
STATE FOR THEIR LEADERSHIP FOR
THAT AND WE WOULD THINK MAYBE
THERE COULD BE A LEGISLATIVE.
IN SET UP OF BLADE TO ENSURE
THAT THERE IS THAT CLAPPER-
ASIAN ACROSS ALL THESE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES THAT SHOULD
BE PART OF THIS CONVERSATION-
COM. AND THEN ONCE THAT'S
UNDERSTOOD. THE NEXT QUESTION
IS MARIO AND MY COLLEAGUES
BROUGHT UP IS HOW DO WE PAY FOR
THIS WE REALLY NEED YOU TO PLAN
BOTH ON THE ENERGY USAGE. AND A
PLAN ON IDENTIFYING THE VARIOUS
FUNDING SOURCES WE APPLY THE-
THREE SIXTY FIVE AND HOPE THAT
GETS OVER THE FINISH LINE THERE
ARE FEDERAL PROGRAMS AND
OPPORTUNITIES OUT THERE WE NEED
STATE SUPPORT TO ACCESS THOSE
DOLLARS. CERTAINLY IT'S MARIO
POINT OUT IT'S THE GOVERNMENT'S
BUDGET- NEEDS TO ASSIST AND
SUPPORT THESE BIG ROBOTS PLANS
AND THEN THE OTHER NOTE IS THAT
THERE ARE A LOT OF GRANTS OUT
THERE. AND IT OFTEN SEEMS LIKE
ONE HANDED IN TALKING TO THE
OTHER HAND THERE'S ALL THESE-
PRESSURES ON THE PORTS TO. MOVE
FORWARD WITHTHESE BIG
ENVIRONMENTAL PROJECTS AND THEN
WE GO AND- APPLY FOR GRANTS AND
THAT WERE NOT ELIGIBLE FOR
GRANTS THERE'S AN EXAMPLE IN
WHEN AMY WHERE WE WANTED TO GO.
TO THE OF THE REGULATION ON ON
THAT BRO BROKE UP.
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR PLUG IN OR
UPON ITS SYSTEM AND- WE WERE
DENIED THE GRANT BECAUSE IT WAS
AN ELIGIBLE FOR VOTES WAGON
FUNDING JUST TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE
BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE A KIND OF
A ONE HAND TALKING THE OTHER
HAND WHEN IT COMES TO GRANDSON
REALLY. INSURING THAT THERE'S
FUNDING OUT THERE FOR US TO DO
BIG THINGS AND CONTINUE TO DO
BIG THINGS- AND THEN JUST IN
CLOSING JUST TO. REITERATE WHAT
YOU'VE HEARD TODAY ARE ARE
WORKERS ARE OUT THERE ON THE
FRONT. LINE WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP BUT IT'S AND
THAT ALL OF OUR CENTER WORKERS
AND HOPE THEY'LL BE. GET THE
SHOTS IN THIS PORTS LIKE
WINNING- WE DON'T WANT TO.
ANYONE IT. TRY SO WITH THAT I
HOPE I MET MY TO TALKED. AND
THANK YOU FOR SPIKE COMMITTEE
PROTECT. DAY LISTENING TO ALL
OF US TIME IN OUR REPORTS. OF
AND THE GOODS MOVE INDUSTRY-
THANK YOU MISTER. AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR- WITH THE
CALIBER. TO CALIFORNIA AIRES'S
RARE RESOURCES BOARD. WAS IN
THE PORTION BE THEIR
PLAYGROUND. THEY SHOULD BE A
PLACE TO PROVIDE JOBS MOVE
GOODS IN AND OUT. BUT THAT WHEN
WE CONTEMPLATE REGULATION IT'S
THOUGHTFUL. ITS TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL- ONE THING IS WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR RESOURCES POOREST
PICKING A TECHNOLOGY IN SAYING
YES THAT'S IT. WHEN IN FACT
THEY SHOULD BE SETTING THE BAR.
THE ISSUE SAYING THIS IS WHAT
WE WANT TO ACHIEVE WITH REGARD
TO A CLEANER GOALS NOT SAYING
THIS IS THE TECHNOLOGY WE WANT
TO YOU TWO YEARS. I THINK
THAT'S VERY PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T IT DOESN'T ALLOW FOR
INNOVATION. SO WE SHOULD NOT
JUST REGULATE BUT WE SHOULD
INNOVATE. AND IT WOULD JUST
REGULATE WE DON'T ALLOW. FOR
OTHER TO BE INNOVATIONS THANK
YOU- SO WITH THAT I DO I WILL
GO TO QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW- AND
I HAVE A QUESTION FROM THE
SENATE YOUR CURRY SHE HAD TO
TAKE OFF AND I THINK HER. UP A
LOT OF FOLKS CONCERN AROUND THE
STATE RIGHT NOW MAYBE THIS GOES
TO MR CORDERO- HAS TO DO WITH-
THE BACKLOG. IN A STATE- THERE
ARE THERE'S A BUNCH OF SHIPS
OUT THERE OFF OF THE COAST OF
LONG BEACH IN LA- THAT ARE
WAITING TO UNLOAD- BECAUSE THE
BACKLOG REPORTS ARE FOR THE
WAREHOUSE WAS OUR FULL COULD
YOU TALK ABOUT THAT SITUATION.
IN A PRETTY EFFICIENT MANNER
AND THEN ALSO ABOUT WHAT THE
WHAT THE- WHAT THE SOLUTION
WITH. WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
OVER TIME WITH REGARD TO THAT
CHALLENGE. WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH OF. ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
THE QUESTION AND IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION BECAUSE LET ME PREFACE
BY SAYING. THIS CERTAINLY SHOWS
THE INTEREST IN STATE WHERE.
THE TOTAL COMMUNITY IT IS THE
GATEWAY TO THE LARGEST KIT WITH
THE COUNTRY AND THE PREFERRED
K. SO IF NOTHING ELSE IT REALLY
GIVES CALIFORNIA. SORT OF A RED
FLAG FOR US AND WE DON'T DO THE
RIGHT THINGS WE WILL NO LONGER
BE A PREFERRED GATEWAY FOR THE
REGION OF WHAT YOU'RE SEEING SO
WHAT WE DO GOING FORWARD FOR
PERMAUL BEACH WE INVEST A LOT
OF. INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS ABOUT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS GOING FORWARD
LITTLE ONE POINT SIX BILLION
BUT TOGETHER. WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN INVEST IN THAT KIND
OF INFRASTRUCTURE TO MOVE
TOWARDS GREATER EFFICIENCY
RELIABILITY AND PREDICTABILITY
SO THAT'S WHAT THE INDUSTRY IS
OUR CUSTOMERS ARE REQUIRED SO
THIS IS WHY WE NEED TO DO THIS
TOGETHER. AND LAST I WILL ALSO
SAY THIS. I THINK IT'S. IT'S A
CONVERSATION I'VE HAD. HER
DAUGHTER WAS AWARE MY VIEWS
THANKS. THIS ABSENT TELLS US
THAT THE NEED FOR US TO GO TO
SEVEN ON. HERE IS COMING TOWARD
ANTI. WE CANNOT THIS TYPE
PARTICLE. HERE TO SORT OF
CALIFORNIA SEVENTEEN MILLION
TOGETHER WITH THE PORTABILITY.
AND EXPECTANT WE'RE NOT HAVING.
ANY CREDIBLE NAKED WE ARE
MAKING PROGRESS MY COLLEAGUE.
AND I AM SURE OKAY. G. STROKING
RETURN OPERATORS WORKING TO.
DEFINITELY THE VISIT OF TWENTY
FOUR SO GONNA COME HERE SIR
THAN LATER. YEAH I KNOW THAT
THE LABOR IS READY TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU I WANNA GO TO ANY
OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE
TODAY IF YOU'D LIKE TO ASK
QUESTIONS. YEAH THREE OF THEM
BOB THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THROUGH THE CHAIR OF. SOME
NOTES HERE WELL I JUST WANTED
TO FIRST THANK ALL THE
PRESENTERS TODAY ALL THE
SPEAKERS- THE- LEARN A LOT. BUT
THE QUESTION I HAVE IS THE
VESSELS THAT ARE OR- WHEN I THE
LANE OR OR OR WAITING THERE-
AND I WANNA JUST ECHO WHAT THE
PORT DIRECTOR- THE OAKLAND IS
THAT. YOU KNOW THAT THE ONE
THING THAT I DO KNOW THAT I'VE
LEARNED FROM BEING HERE. IS
THAT WE GOTTA HAVE A PLAN WE
GOT TO CONTINUE TO HAVE A PLAN
I MEAN IT'S- IT'S NOT SOMETHING
TO THE PLANNED FOR TOMORROW BUT
WE NEED TO PLAN FOR TODAY AND
IF WE COULD WORK- WITH. ALL OF
THE PORTS YOU KNOW TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT. HOW WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER BECAUSE- BOTTOM LINE
YOU KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO
COMPETITION- WE'RE COMPETE
WE'RE COMPETING WITH FOLKS
FROM. YOU KNOW PEACE IT- BACK
EAST AND WHEN WORKING ONE THING
THAT I ALSO KNOW IS THAT WHEN
IT COMES OF VENDORS. THEY'RE
GONNA GO TO FOLKS THAT ARE
EITHER. BETTER FASTER AND- AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU KNOW
OUR LOCAL BUSINESSES RIGHT SO.
I'M HOPING THAT WE COULD ALL
COME TOGETHER AND MAKING SURE
THAT I CAN YOU KNOW WE CAN ECHO
WHAT WITH THE DIRECTOR OF
OAKLAND SAID IS THAT WE GOT IT
WE GOTTA FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER. AND CREATE A
PLAN SO THAT'S JUST A COMMENT-
MISTER CHAIRMAN SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND I APPRECIATE
HAVING SOMEONE FROM THE PORT OF
STOCKTON HERE THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE IN THE STATES
I MEAN OUR OUR AREA WE'RE WE
HAVE- WE'RE TRUCKING HUB AND I
WAS GLAD THAT THE- CITY IT WAS
HERE YOU KNOW WE ARE TRACKING
HUB YOU KNOW WEEK WEEK TO MOVE
CARGO WE HAVE WAREHOUSES. IN
OUR DISTRICT AND- YOU KNOW
WE'RE READY TO GO SO WE WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO- THE PORT OF
STOCKTON- IS LOOKING FORWARD TO
BEING A BIG. PART OF TRYING TO
HELP HELP THE SOLUTION. THANK
YOU GIBSON DID YOU TO. IT IS ON
HAVE AS FEDERAL. I'M KNOW IF G.
PERSONAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN. AND TO ALL THE
PRESENTERS FOR BEING HERE. I
DON'T KNOW OF GENES- IS STILL
IS STILL HERE BUT I JUST HAVE
ONE QUESTION- WHAT ACTIONS OR
LEGISLATION CAN THE STATE WORK
ON TO GET. THE PORTS BACK ON
TRACK POST CODE EX NINETEEN. I
THINK WE SHOULD FIGURE OUT.
WHAT THAT PLAN SHOULD BE AS- A
TERMINAL DIAL INDICATED THERE
IS A LOT OF. VESSELS THAT
AWAITING- IN WATERS TO TRY TO
GET IN WHAT IT WHAT SHOULD WE
BE WORKING ON RIGHT NOW TO TRY
TO GET. THINGS BACK ON TRACK-
THAT'S POST CODE NINETEEN. SO
WHERE WAS THE ADDRESS THAT YOU
WILL LOVE. COMPLAINTS I CAN
ADDRESS THAT SOMETHING AND TAKE
YOUR QUESTION I THINK THERE'S
TWO THINGS NUMBER ONE I'D BE
REMISS NOT TO SAY THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESSES. OF PORT RELIEVES
YOU KNOW WE ARE DOING THAT AT A
VERY ACTIVE LEVEL AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. COURSE AT THE
STATE LEVEL. OBVIOUSLY YOU SEEN
THIS INDUSTRY RESEARCH
OPERATION HAS WORKED DAY IN AND
DAY OUT OUR MEN AND WOMEN ON
THE WATERFRONT. JUST BEGINNING
OF THIS CRISIS SO THE FIRST
PART OF THAT- MY ANSWER IS UP
FOR RELIEF WITH REGARD TO WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN THE EXPENDITURES
THAT WE MADE HERE. THE PORT
DISTRICT. NUMBER TWO IS REGARD
TO WHAT WE DO TOGETHER TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE THIS WORK OF
FICTION. AND I THINK THE
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE
PARTICULARLY RAIL. RAIL IS THE
FUTURE IN TERMS OF HELPING MOVE
CONTAINERS MORE EFFICIENTLY
AND- WITH IT. A FRIENDLIER
ENVIRONMENTAL FOOTPRINT SO I
THINK BECAUSE- OF THE WORK
NEEDED TO RECESSED PORTS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CREATE
EFFICIENCIES AND CONGESTION. I
THINK THE BETTER. AND I THINK
THE LOSSES WHAT I SAID
PREVIOUSLY. THANK YOU US THIS
POLICY AND LIKE COLLEAGUE- DAY.
DANIELLE THE BOOK. JUST BASIC
MISTER WE NEED UP AND THAT PLAN
SOME CAN MY MIND HAS INCLUDE A-
ANY FURTHERING A TWO OF COURSE
VISION CARE WE NEED TO WORK
SUPPORT UP NIGHT AND DAY AND
LIKE I SAID BEFORE. LABOUR'S
RIGHT TO DO THAT. THANK YOU
CENTER GUNS ALL DID YOU WISH TO
SHARE ANY ON SOCIAL COUNTY
FIRST I APOLOGIZE. I DON'T HEAR
HER RIGHT NOW SO WE'LL GO TO
THE LINE- JUST JUST QUICKLY
JUST TO MAYBE I SHOULD HAVE A-
MR VANDENBERG PLEASE EXPLAIN
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ZERO AND
NEAR ZERO. AND WHY NIGHT NEAR
ZERO MIGHT BE SOMETHING THAT WE
WANT TO. TO PAY MORE FOCUS ON
IN THE IN THE SHORT TERM.
MISTER VANDENBERG ARE YOU STILL
ON YEAH. YES I AM. THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION SO I DO THINK
THE THIRD SO WHAT WE NEED TO
LOOK AS A MULTI TIERED STRATEGY
TO MOVE FORWARD. AND TO YOU I
HATE TO USE A SPORTS ANALOGY
BUT- YOU DO WANT TO LOOK AT
JUST WHERE THE BALL IS TODAY
BUT WHERE DO YOU NEED TO HAVE
THE BALL DOWN THE ROAD. BUT I
THINK TODAY WE CAN DEFINITELY
GET WHAT PEOPLE CALL NEAR ZERO
OR CULTURAL LOAD BOX TRUCKS-
FURTHER OUT INTO USE. THAT
WOULD BE PARTICULARLY THAT
RIGHT NOW IT'S NATURAL GAS WITH
LOW KNOCKS ENGINES. THEY'RE
MUCH LOWER THE 90% CLEANER THAN
DIESEL. AND THEY CAN USE
RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS SO THEY
CAN GIVE US. THE BENEFITS OF
CLEANER AIR AS WELL AS CLIMATE
ACTION. AT THE SAME TIME I
THINK WE NEED O HAVE AT THE
SAME TIME A PARALLEL STRATEGY
TO KEEP MOVING FORWARD. ZERO
WHICH MEANS NOTHING OUT OF THE
TAIL PIPE. SO ZERO EMISSIONS
FOUR CRITERIA MITTENS WITHIN
THE REGION. AS WELL AS MOVING
TOWARDS BECAUSE OF WHERE THE-
UTILITY GRID IS GOING. ZERO
EMISSIONS FOR CLIMATE AS WELL
WE SHOULD BE. IN THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGION APPROACHING
EIGHTY PERCENT. A REDUCTION AND
CLIMATE IN POWER PRODUCTION. SO
THAT MEANS ANYTHING USING THAT
POWER IS GOING TO BE EIGHTY
PERCENT. LOWER ALREADY. AND
THEN SIR MISSION DR TRAITS OR
ELECTRIC DRIVE TRAINS ARE MORE
EFFICIENT THAN CONVENTIONAL
DRIVETRAINS SO THEY WILL GET
YOU EVEN FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD.
SO I THINK IT GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO. SOMETHING
THAT'S A LOW EMISSION
COMBUSTION ENGINE. SUCH AS LOW
KNOCKS NATURAL GAS NOW. GET
THOSE OUT IN THIS INTERIM
PERIOD BUT START THIS FILL IN
THE GAPS. AS ELECTRIC MOVES
ONLINE AND FRANKLY ELECTRIC IS
GOING TO BE SCALING OVER THE
NEXT. EIGHT TO NINE YEARS. SO
IT'S A DUAL PHASE TRACK IF YOU
WILL. I THANK YOU. AND I THINK
WHAT YOU POINT OUT VERY SIMPLY
JUST HAVING ELECTRIC TRUCK IS
ENOUGH. THERE ARE MANY THAT ARE
COMMERCIALLY VIABLE IN THE
HEAVY AND RIGHT NOW IF ANY. OF
BUT YOU STILL NEED TO HAVE THE
UTILITIES TO FEED THOSE TRUCKS.
AND THOSE ARE SIGNIFICANT DRAWS
ON POWER- AND SO THERE IS NOT
JUST THE TRUCK BUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO CHARGE THAT
TRUCK. IF YOU'RE GOING. TO
DEMAND THAT IT. ONLY BE
ELECTRIC OR HYDROGEN AND SOME
OTHER SOURCES OUT THERE MIGHT
WORK. AS WELL HUNDRED TRUCK
ACTUALLY IS ELECTRIC TRUCK
RIGHT AND- IT'S A GENERATOR.
BEING POWER BY ABSOLUTELY. IT'S
THE SAME THING EXCEPT WHERE TO
THE ELECTRONS COME FROM AND IN
THE CASE OF A- FUEL CELL TRUCK-
THE ELECTRONS ARE COMING FROM
STORED HYDROGEN. THE THING GETS
TURNED INTO ELECTRICITY BUT THE
POWER TRAIN IS THE. EXACT SAME
AS A BATTERY ELECTRIC TRUCK.
GREAT THANK YOU I WITH THAT
WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE- WE DON'T
TIME SHE KEEP YOUR YOUR CALL.
TO ABOUT THIRTY SECONDS MAX
BECAUSE I HAVE TO CATCH A
PLANE. SO WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
PHONES AND IF. ANYONE GETS OFF
TOPIC IS OFF TOPIC JUST PLEASE
OPERATOR MOVE FORWARD CUT THEM
OFF AND REMOVED MYTHOLOGY. THE
TOPIC TODAY IS- THE PORTS GOOD
MOVEMENT. AND RESPONDING TO
COVER NINETEEN GOING CLEAN AND
GREEN THAT IS WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY. SO THAT TO
THE PHONES. THANK YOU AYE
LADIES INTERMINABLE LINES IF
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE PUBLIC
KOMPLETT COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE. FOLLOWED BY ZERO. PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
OPERATORS GOING TO GIVE YOU
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE. SO
YOU CAN ASK YOUR QUESTION
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME FOR QUESTIONS AND OUR
FIRST QUESTION COMES FROM WIND
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY THAT ROLE. GO AHEAD OF YOU
MAY SPEAK. RIGHT MANY PARTS
BECAUSE AFTER ALL NEEDS TO
CATCH A PLANE THAT'S MORE
IMPORTANT THAN ME BEING TWENTY
FIRST THEN. NEXT CALL. EIGHT
THINK THAT. NEXT WE WILL IF YOU
PUBLIC COM PLEASE GO AHEAD AND
HIT- WHY ZERO JUST. AND WE HAVE
SOMEBODY QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT.
IF I DIDN'T TAKE THE PLAN DROVE
GASES. THE MOBILE LINE SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS DENNIS DARBY RD AND- TO
FIND ON BEHALF OF THE ALL THE
LAND CALIFORNIA AND AS WELL AS
OTHER AGRICULTURAL INTERESTS WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE ACTIVITIES
OF THE PORK PROVIDES 80% OF THE
ALMONDS IN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA- SENT OVERSEAS.
SEVERAL OTHER COMMODITIES SUCH
AS ORANGES AND COTTON A RELY ON
THE PORCH VERY WELL FOR
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE IMPROVEMENTS
THAT THE- THAT THAT ARE
DISCUSSED TODAY INCLUDING ZERO
AT AND NEAR ZERO EMISSION.
VEHICLES SAID AND WE HAVE BEEN
UPDATED OUR TEACHERS WELL WE DO
WANT TO ENCOURAGE A THOUSAND
LOOK AT BRINGING IN THE PORCH
AT THAT IS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
GET THROUGH PUT FOLLOW AT EIGHT
PM EST YOU KNOW. WE SHOULD THE
MATTER AND THAT GETTING
PRODUCTS. ACROSS IN THE
INTERNATIONAL OF THE STATE YOU
LIVE. AND HAVE BEEN IMPACT
REEFS- READ CAN BACK TO ASIA.
AND WE JUST WANT TO. THAT ISSUE
DOESN'T FALL OFF THE TABLE AS
WE LOOK AT TRYING TO MAKE
COURTS MORE EFFICIENT AND
GREEN- WE ALSO NEED TO BE ABLE
TO. GET BACK CALLS OF
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURAL
BOUNTY ACROSS THE WATERS AND
SHOWS WE DO WE LOOK FOR TO BE
PART OF THE CONVERSATION PART
OF THE SOLUTION APPRECIATE THE
TIME TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER ELBASANI REMINDING US
THAT WE'RE NOT ONLY IMPORTING
OR EXPORTING AND A LOT OF THOSE
EXPORTS ARE FROM CALIFORNIA
WALNUTS EXEDRA COTTON SO THANK
YOU AND WE NEED TO GET IT OFF
THE DOCKS. WITH IT WILL GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. FOR
ADDITIONAL. ADDITIONAL OUR-
PUBLIC COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. SECURE
NOBODY OF QUEUING UP. THE CARE
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME. NO NO FURTHER CALLS.
THANK YOU WE WILL NOT ALL THE
HEARING TO AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL THE PARTICIPANTS. IN
PARTICULAR- I WANT TO THANK US
CERTAINLY MARTIN OF THE MARTHA
MILLER FOR HELPING ORGANIZE
THIS KILEY FOR MY OFFICE AS
WELL. THE FRANK MURPHY REPAIRS-
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON
INFRASTRUCTURE RAMON PONCE
DAILY ON ON THE IMPACT THE
WORKERS ON THE DOCK- THANK YOU
FOR REPRESENTING THEM RACHEL
MICHELIN REMINDING US THAT
BUSINESS SHOULD HAVE A VOICE
IN. AND DEVELOPING REGULATIONS
TO ANYONE- TALK ABOUT THE PORT
OF OAKLAND AND HOW UNIQUE THEY
ARE ELAINE FORBES OF THE
IMPACTS TO FIND IT FINANCIAL
IMPACTS IN PARTICULAR. OF
COVERT NINETEEN ON THE SAN
FRANCISCO PORPOISES MUCH
PROPERTY ALONG THE WATERFRONT
THEIR BILL THEN AMBERG I
DISCUSSING ZERO ZERO ZERO IN IN
THE IN OUR EFFORTS TO GET THERE
FROM IT THE INDUSTRY THAT DOES
PROVIDE THOSE MACHINES. MAKE
JACOB- TALK ABOUT SHORE POWER
AND A LOT OF OTHER THINGS THAT
PMSA HAS PARTICIPATED IN AND
HAS BEEN. A SUPPORTER OF AND
THAT IS NOT EASY WE SHOULD
RECOGNIZE THAT CHRISTIAN MONA
FROM- CTA THE CALIFORNIA
TRUCKERS ASSOCIATION TALKING
ABOUT HOW THEY'VE GIVEN A LOT
THEY'RE WILLING TO GIVE MORE.
BUT- THEY'VE GIVEN OVER THE
CLEAN UP OUR TRUCKING ABOUT 80%
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
STILL BUT MORE TO DO THAN
WILLING TO BE A PARTNER BUT IT
IS EXPENSIVE EXPENSIVE. AND WE
NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT MARIO
CORDERO OWES A GREAT VOICE FOR
THE PORT OF LONG BEACH AND
BEYOND TALKING ABOUT THE
HISTORY IN LONG BEACH. AND WHAT
WE'VE DONE THERE TO CLEAN UP
THE AIR. AND KRISTEN DEAK- FROM
THE OF WINE. BILL AGAIN BEING A
GREAT. AND EXPLAINING WHAT
THEY'VE DONE TO CLEANING GREEN
OUR AIR WITH THAT I THINK THE
PARTICIPANTS- TODAY AND-
APPRECIATE ALL THOSE WHO. WHO
PARTICIPATED WE WILL OTHER
HEARINGS AND WE'LL DELVE INTO
MORE TOPICS AND I WANNA THANK
YOU FOR A HEALTHY AND FRUITFUL.
THANK YOU. HI THIS HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.